what does a monster look like to you
what figures Slither and Claw their way
into your nightmares chasing you down
endless halls and stalking you through
the dark until you wake up screaming
maybe you imagine something tall and
lean bony arms reaching for you from
atop impossibly long slender legs its
featureless face showing no mercy maybe
you think of a man in a striped sweater
with knives for fingers or a serial
killer in a hockey mask wielding the
machete maybe it's something more
inhuman a cosmic horror of tentacles and
eyes that can see into your very Soul
you probably don't think of something
with no arms no legs no body at all just
a face What's So Scary About That a face
can't run after you can't grab you by
the ankles and pull you under the bed a
face can only look it may be unsettling
to behold it might send a chilled on
your spine but the worse it can do is
make you a little uncomfortable and if
you can't stand it any longer you could
always just close your eyes but walk
away and be done with it right if that's
what you think if you don't believe in
monsters that can hurt you without
lifting a finger then you're the type to
fall victim to a very special very
intelligent mask in the hollowed Halls
of the SCP Foundation there is a
containment cell outfitted with a
hermetically sealed glass case
surrounded by steel iron and Lead there
are guards posted outside along with a
trained psychologist if you are ever
Brave and foolish enough to enter that
room you'll see a simple white porcelain
comedy mask with a peculiar black
substance leaking from its eye eyes and
mouth whatever this slime touches
surfaces begin to corrode to rot away
into puddles of black liquid you might
notice the same liquid trickling slowly
down the walls of the room corrupting
everything in its path as unsettling of
a sight as it is if you approach The
Mask to take a closer look you will find
yourself overcome by an intense nearly
irresistible urge to pick it up and put
it on to wear it to let it consume you
from the inside out and puppet your body
while your brain simply turns off like
an extinguished flame you'll simply be
gone then who knows what the mask will
do it won't be your concern anymore
that's for sure but thankfully you
haven't gone into the room with the
porcelain mask you haven't let It cast
its spell on you not yet at least it's
waiting for you there in the room with
black slime oozing down its walls and it
will wait patiently for as long as it
needs to after all what's a mask without
a face to wear it
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask sat in its containment cell
immobile as always it didn't really have
much of a choice in the matter the
foundation had chosen selfishly to
revoke its host privileges once upon a
time they offered it bodies to choose
from mannequins dummies and wooden dolls
that could Adorn and pilot it didn't
last as long as an organic living host
of course but it was something it was a
taste of Freedom this Dreadful new
situation was almost enough to make the
mask want to change its surroundings
this Dreadful new situation was almost
enough to make the mask want to change
its expression from Comedy to tragedy
but it was to determined to still find
something to laugh about even without a
body trapped in this infernal box there
had been some delicious opportunities
for entertainment human Minds were
fragile things the mask had learned this
over the infinite years of its life if
one could call it a life apply the right
kind of pressure to the right weak
points whisper an enticing word or two
find the right emotional wound to
sprinkle a pinch of salt into and humans
would Buckle completely in almost no
time at all it had tried all sorts of
methods since being confined to this
boring little box sometimes it would
charm someone pour honeyed flattery into
their heads until the person felt like
the mask was a dear friend a confidant
one suitable trust had been built up the
mass could persuade the person to bring
it a host or perhaps even offer up
themselves in sacrifice it if flattery
didn't work there were other potent
approaches to take for a being without
ears the mask was a good listener he
picked up on things that no human ever
could the darkest Secrets buried in a
person's mind if it caught wind of
something especially juicy and ruinous
it could leverage that threatened to
expose an affair a crime or perhaps
something even worse something
unspeakable if praise failed and so did
blackmail there was always good old
Supernatural intimidation all the mask
needed was for someone to be left alone
with it for a long enough period of time
then its invisible tendrils could snake
out into their defenseless mind weaving
and poking around leaving a lingering
sense of cold dread of incomprehensible
Whispers in Long dead on
es what a delight containment had been
in the early days when the foundation
had not yet figured out the mask's true
capabilities when they would leave
security personnel with weak wills and
minimal training standing guard in the
mask's field of influence for hours at a
time as the entity played with their
thoughts and chipped away at their free
will thanks to the helpers that had been
able to mold out of those hapless
victims they had been there to break
open its case and carry it to freedom
but every time the other guards thwarted
the attempts shooting its helpers and
rendering them utterly useless then the
foundation increased its security
something about the unacceptably high
homicide rates among staff assigned to
scp-035 how utterly boring how truly
pathetic still The Mask had found ways
to occupy itself even without any more
plaything
it had grown stronger with its boredom
stretching its influence Beyond Organic
beings and into the very room itself
it's evil enriching and deepening like a
fine wine in the depths of a cold cellar
over the months the walls of scp-035's
containment cell had begun to secrete
the same black slimy substance that
would pour from the mask's eyes and
mouth the liquid dripped Down the Walls
in deliberate formations patterns that
became increasingly easy to recognize
Praises in Italian Latin ancient Greek
all detailing ritual sacrifices and
mutilations The Mask took time to
describe the sacrificial victims in
great detail borrowing identifying
traits from various staff members so
that it knew would read the translations
the walls were slick with blood and
harrowing imagery and the glass case
around the mask was growing more and
more Fragile by the day anyone within 10
meters of the mass could feel this
strength too they would leave the area
complaining of unintelligible Whispers
of loud cruel laughter and a lingering
sense of nearly insurmountable despair
it was as if they knew on some level
that no one was truly safe eventually
The Mask would find a way to come for
them all the glass was weakening and
soon the mere thought of Escape would
make it shatter into pieces then perhaps
the mass could finally get its deepest
desire
Revenge it wanted nothing more than to
try to make the foundation pay for
imprisoning it for taking away its host
privileges for trying harder and harder
to contain the kind of power that should
have had them falling to their knees in
worship the mask seethed with hatred day
in and day out it had seen the crumbling
of the Roman Empire the beheading of
King
decimation of armies it was not going to
be captured by a bunch of rats in lab
coats without dire consequences
befalling them maybe it couldn't move
from its prison cell at the moment but
it also knew that it was surrounded on
all sides by dangerous beasts capable of
reducing the sight and all who had dared
to oppose the mask to a pile of
smoldering Rubble if it could only find
its way onto one of their faces it would
show them all just what it was capable
of as the piercing sound of an alarm
echoed down the hall the sound of
Screams and Chaos following shortly
after the mask's frowning face curved
into a broad menacing smile what was it
that had escaped the lizard perhaps the
giant grinning man whatever it was it
seemed that the action was heading right
towards 0-3-5's containment cell perhap
perhaps today was the day finally the
SCP Foundation would fall outside the
mask's cell security officer Harper was
running for dear life those more
rational mind knew he was living on
seconds not even minutes of borrowed
time his animal brain kept his legs
pumping desperately trying to avoid the
screaming howling Predator Hot on his
heels Harper looked over his shoulder
and screamed as a long white arm reached
for him
scp-096 the shy guy it's tooth line jaw
hanging low and foaming with spittle
that face that terrible terrible face an
absolute death sentence to all who saw
it he'd seen what he thought was a crack
in the otherwise perfect seal of 096's
containment chamber but it could have
just as easily been a trick of the light
not even thinking he stepped forward and
looked at the vulnerability in the
chamber all it took was one misplay ray
of light and he made out the vague shape
of a face in the darkness that's when
the Weeping started Harper knew in that
moment his life was over the correct
thing to do would have been to order
everyone else in the room to close their
eyes while he stood there and accepted
his fate minimizing the risk of
spreading the damage further but humans
rarely have perfect reasoning even less
so when facing mortality back in the
present the shy guy made a perfect lunge
grabbing Harper and its iron clutches
and barreling through the adjoining wall
the nearby guards scattered terrified
keeping their eyes on the floor they
might get a slap on the wrist for
temporarily abandoning their posts but
they weren't going to die guarding some
stupid evil mask speaking of the
possessive mask was surprised to feel
two new presences enter its chamber
through the now destroyed wall these two
presences soon became just one as
scp-096 quickly and totally annihilated
security officer Harper leaving nothing
left the mask couldn't see per se seeing
as it had no actual sensory organs but
it felt around this new guest with its
many psychic tendrils taking in this
strange totality the creature was
powerful no doubt about that and it
elicited fear from those fools at the
SCP Foundation but the mask noticed its
brain waves were extraordinarily muted
humans to The Masks vast and malicious
Consciousness weren't the sharpest
knives in the drawer but compared to
this thing's mine they were a pile of
tempered katanas it barely thought it
all the mask would have to dig deeper to
find anything it could use meanwhile
scp-096 finally began to calm down the
one who had seen it had been annihilated
bubbling rage was slowly siphoned out
and replaced by the standard low but
constant home of anxiety and despair it
would wait until its head was bagged and
it was dragged back to the dark same old
same old all the way to the end of time
that's when it felt something else it
started as a faint Buzz an
unintelligible whisper and it was almost
like a door opened in the back of its
head something stepped in and took a
seat
can you hear me stranger
luck
I want to speak to you something about
the voice frightened and comforted as
cp096 at the same time it spoke with a
greater degree of sympathy and the
creature had heard in a long time and
yet something about the way it spoke
implied evil in its intent
I know what you fear
wouldn't it be nice if they could ever
look into again
little by little 096 felt more of these
strange thoughts filling up the
emptiness in its head replacing the few
little thoughts the creature itself had
it felt itself lifting its hands from
the ground lifting them and reaching
towards something a glass box
the glass shattered and those long white
fingers reached for something within a
mask just like the voice had said a mask
to stop people from looking at its face
yes yes
[Music]
scp-096 lifted The Mask to its face
feeling black liquid that burned its
skin dripping from the porcelain and put
it on and in that moment everything
changed the Shy Guy's body began to
seize up rattling as the mask Unleashed
a web of psychic tendrils through its
body mapping out across every inch like
a new nervous system taking control the
possessive mask had never experienced a
host like this before that incredible
perfect mix of physical durability and a
mind so insubstantial that it was easy
to sublimate
for the first time the shy guy now under
the full control of the possessive mask
stood at full height on its hind legs
his spine and shoulders clicking into
place for its new stance The Mask
cracked its neck getting used to the new
dimensions of its physicality its
indestructible bones its long grasping
limbs its skin burning and fizzling with
the gooey black secretions but growing
back just as quickly the foundation had
every reason to fear it now a group of
security Personnel had gathered in the
Ragged hole where the chamber's north
wall used to be some were wielding light
Firearms the guard at the front was
carrying an opaque black bag The Mask
laughed with its new body and turned to
the crowd the second they saw it on
096's body their faces fell for a moment
their bodies went slack with Terror this
situation was unprecedented what course
of action could they possibly take at a
time like this they looked at the bag
held by the leader of the security force
and projected a single thought into his
mind
before any of the guards even had a
chance to open fire The Mask lunged
forwards using the long terrible arms of
the shy guy to tear through the guards
they were dead in seconds their bodies
strewn about the hallway the mask's
porcelain was twisted into a wide
sadistic grin it could tell that it was
about to have some real fun around here
and once it slaughtered everyone here it
could finally stretch its legs out in
the open again true freedom to spread
misery fear and pain everywhere it went
there were just a few hundred members of
foundation Personnel it needed to turn
into corpses first more Containment
Breach alarms sounded around the site as
the mask began its Rampage running
through the hallways and tearing apart
any unfortunate Foundation Personnel it
could get 096's Hands-On guards
researchers administrative staff and
even one egg extremely unlucky janitor
in hallway C6 it was having the time of
its long and terrible life and much to
its Glee it seemed that this new host's
body was still holding up it was perfect
symbiosis a twisted brilliant mind and a
body that could forever support it there
would be no stopping it a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around
the site soon realized on their own
terms 096 was indestructible but it was
dumb as a brick and had an easily
exploitable weakness get the bag on its
head and you're home free this new
composite creature was a different story
he could think tactically avoiding
head-on confrontations in favor of sneak
attacks and the monster had as much
psychic combat potential as physical
guards roving the building in teams
heavily armed with anti-memetic
protective gear still reported feeling
immense feelings of psychological dread
overcomes that was the greatest sign
that the mask would come bursting
through the wall moments later and tear
them to
the site director put out an urgent call
for all nearby mobile task forces to
intercept and help them take care of the
unfortunate situation thankfully a
Detachment of MTF 8-10 also known as see
no evil was operating on a case in close
proximity given their specialization and
anomalies within the medic visual
property many on the team had dealt with
096 breaches before that at least gave
them experience in half of this
situation and one operative among them
Sergeant henrique Ramirez would be the
one to bring this nightmare to an end
but it would cost him his life in the
process the mask was still using its new
indestructible body to wreak havoc on
the containment site once it had taken
out the primary contingents of guards it
was free to have its fun with the rest
stalking defenseless researchers through
the Halls making sure to induce maximum
Terror before finally striking the
killing blow every single one of them
died with a headphone demonic Whispers
it told them that the mask's Eternal
Dominion now it had found the perfect
host nothing on Earth would stop it
humans would be mere ants under its feet
Ada 10 touched down and entered the
building Ramirez was Point man leading
the others into the bowels of the
blood-drenched containment site they'd
been briefed on what they were heading
in for 096 and 035 had reached symbiosis
and were displaying unprecedented
anomalous effects enter with Extreme
Caution they're beyond dangerous even
more so together than alone ideally
Ramirez would have wanted to go in with
a comprehensive plan but lives were on
the line here they needed to leap off
the cliff and build their wings on the
way down it was only when they finally
encountered the monster that they
realized just how outmatched they were
despite their best efforts the combined
speed intelligence and ferocity of the
mask's new form allowed it to make short
work of of 8-10 only Ramirez was left
heavily injured even if a miracle
happened we knew he wasn't getting out
of here alive The Mask grabbed him with
one of 096's Claws and lifted him up it
would take its time with this one make
him suffer watch him squirm destroy his
mind Ramirez felt the mask's psychic
tendrils penetrate the membrane of his
mind those Whispers those terrible
Whispers reciting all his worst fears
with terrible Glee his gun was out of
ammo his knife was broken all he had
left on him was a pocket mirror and that
was his Eureka moment it was a long shot
but it was also his only shot he reached
out and grabbed the bottom of the Mask
pulling for dear life his other hand
shot into his pocket and grabbed the
mirror opening its lid with a Deft flick
of his thumb it was too fast for the
mass to even register what was going on
Ramirez forced his eyes shut and lifted
up the mirror The Mask saw its own
reflection in the glass as the bottom of
its face came loose revealing the
reflection of the face underneath the
mask squeezed killing Ramirez but it was
already too late it had finally seen the
face of its host and that would cost it
dearly The Mask felt a sudden and
tremendous pushback to its psychic
forces a blind Despair and then rage
that choked out everything
scp-096 began to sob and howl somehow
the mask was no longer in control
despite its psychic protests 096 reached
up and tore the terrible mask from its
face tossing it against the wall with
such force that it was embedded in the
brickwork its last thoughts as other
mobile task force operators descended on
the area to bag096 and return it to its
containment chamber were
the hell just happened and the next
thought that crossed the mind of the
site director was request site transfer
for zero three five as soon as possible
don't want a repeat of this incident
anytime soon it's an unusually calm
moment in the SCP Foundation no one is
in the hall besides a scientist and a
young female subject there are no tests
going on just observation
the scientist calmly asks her questions
as he escorts her down the hallway
hoping to get more insight into her
unique abilities so why does she look so
utterly terrified as the scientist tries
to get her attention the young woman
becomes more preoccupied staring
nervously around the hallway does she
fear the scientist why does she keep
muttering strange phrases that don't
make any sense how do they break through
such a heavy door a door is nearly a
foot thick how did it manage to destroy
it the scientist is looking at his notes
and tries to make sense of the young
woman's statements when he notices
something terrible she's staring at one
of the doors containing another highly
dangerous SCP in top of the line
restraints but it's safely locked away
right the scientist swears he can hear
the sound of scratching behind the steel
door it was 17 hours later when the
dangerous SCP broke out of its
containment cell and could have laid
ways to the entire SCP container
facility if it wasn't for the heavily
armed Response Team waiting outside to
contain it and return it to itself the
huge loss of life was only avoided
because the SCP Foundation had advanced
warning all thanks to the greatest
secret weapon the foundation has ever
seen
scp-187 But the foundation's most
powerful defense against dangerous scps
is probably its most unlikely a
completely normal looking young woman in
her early 20s whose only distinguishing
characteristic is how thin and haunted
she looks despite being no danger to
anyone in the foundation she's one of
the most carefully guarded scps in the
facility to protect her from herself
scp-187 is one of the most powerful
precognitives ever found but her
abilities are a danger to her own mind
this average looking girl has a unique
telepathic ability where she can see
into the future of whatever she's
looking at seeing it simultaneously in
two frames of existence she sees it as
it is now as well as what it will look
like in the future say for instance
she's looking at a baby tiger cub oh
cute
at the same time she also sees the
massive fearsome jungle beast it'll
become she won't see minor changes to
its state so she won't be able to tell
you how your next haircut will look but
if something drastic is about to happen
to someone or something she'll be able
to predict it with perfect accuracy
there's only one problem
she can't turn it off
this involuntary ability goes off
whenever she sees someone or something
that's about to undergo a major change
in its status this means that at any
time she can be bombarded with horrible
visuals and that even include food
ever since her abilities kicked in
scp-187 has been unable to eat normally
because whatever she eats or drinks she
sees it in its future State when she
looks at a glass of water she'll see it
as a liquid but a little more yellow
than it usually is
as for solid food she'll see it as what
it comes out as after it's been digested
not exactly appetizing so for a while it
looked like she was likely to starve
herself to death in the foundation's
custody fortunately the administration
scientists were able to find some
workarounds around her ability feeding
and hydrating her intravenously was an
option but further study of her
abilities made clear that her power was
processed through her eyes that means
that when she's blindfolded she's able
to eat without her precognition kicking
in being assigned to the detail for
scp-187 is very different from most SCP
details if you're assigned to scp-682
you're constantly worried that the
horrible carnivorous Beast with a hatred
for all things human is going to get
loose and tear you to shreds not so much
with scp-187 this duty is more like a
medical team where the patient is highly
valuable to the institution and can't be
allowed to get free or to harm
themselves in any way the foundation has
taken the highest precautions to ensure
scp-187 is safe including a set of
medical restraints that she's strapped
into except when out of her cell are
participating in tests even when given
more freedom her hands are always in
soft mittens to keep her from trying to
damage her own eyes as a way to
neutralize her powers her team
blindfolds her before every meal time
and feeds her with some mild sedatives
added to her food to keep her calm
through consistent care she's starting
to recover from her self-induced
starvation the Personnel chosen for this
assignment are carefully screened before
being sent in to interact with her they
need to be the most responsible and
detail-oriented members of the staff who
won't miss a thing when it comes to her
care routine just because 187 is
harmless doesn't mean she can't move
fast and one misstep could cost the
foundation their most valuable asset
and unlike most scps 187 is rarely
handled by d-class Personnel they don't
have access to higher security specimens
and they don't have the training due to
their short tenure but there's another
reason the foundation keeps 187 away
from the lowest men on the totem pole
d-class Personnel are frequently used to
test out dangerous scps and are lucky if
they get to end their service intact
when she was exposed to some d-class
Personnel early in her stay she saw them
as horribly bloated with holes in their
heads or missing half their body those
unfortunate Personnel soon met horrible
Fates sucked out into the vacuum of
space shot while trying to escape and
bitten in half by an escaping anomalous
creature additionally While most d-class
Personnel are anesthetized after their
service some are terminated for breaking
protocol or trying to escape
scp-187 would see any of these
unfortunate Personnel walking around as
the corpses they'd wind up as the the
foundation wants to learn the full
extent of her powers though and this
means tests lots of tests when she first
came into the foundation's care they
were focused on figuring out how her
power worked they gave her IQ tests and
she got every answer right on the
written test her IQ was measured as
being off the charts at least 300 which
would make her the smartest person alive
but her normal behavior didn't seem to
match up with this level of super
intelligence confusing them even more
when she was given a computerized IQ
test she scored slightly below average
with a score of 97. the scientists
assigned to her case studied the results
and created other tests until they
understood how her precognitive ability
works
we can see the future of anything that's
physically affected so when an answer is
marked down on a piece of paper that's a
notable change but when an entry is
typed into a computer the computer
Remains the Same so her ability wasn't
able to help her on the computerized
tests but her abilities could still help
the foundation especially when it comes
to improving security for other
anomalies she had inadvertently
prevented The Escape of an especially
deadly SCP creature by predicting it
would break through the door but how
would her powers manifest in more
complicated cases some Foundation
researchers postulated that she might be
able to see into the future of deadly
indestructible anomalies like scp-682
and figure out a way to eliminate it but
temporal experts warned this could
create a paradox
after all she would be looking at an
elimination protocol that didn't exist
until she looked at it but her powers
and how they might help in other ways
other than neutralization warranted
further exploration so Personnel were
assigned and the scp-187 experiments
began
scp-162 is a horrible mass of Fish Hooks
wire and other sharp implements it
exudes a psychological pull and any
unfortunate person who touches it winds
up being pulled in by the barbed objects
and absorbed into its mass
scp-187 was kept at a safe distance and
examined it and was undisturbed she saw
it only as a pile of melted slag
indicating that it would be neutralized
at some point
scp-529 a normal and friendly cat except
for the fact that its back half appears
to be completely missing the cat acts as
if it's whole and when scp-187 was
exposed to it she didn't seem to notice
anything wrong with the cat she played
with it briefly and seemed to be calmer
than any other time she was examined the
foundation is considering using scp-529
as a motivating tool after she requested
to revisit it other tasks had much more
disturbing results as scp-187 discovered
things about subjects that researchers
were previously unaware of
scp-003 a strange organic circuit board
made of hair and nails attached to a
stone tablet appears to be an ancient
machine but when scp-187 was introduced
to it she greeted it like a person and
had a conversation with it as the staff
looked on confused when she was
interviewed after she described The
Entity as a very nice lady what is
scp-003 evolving into the foundation is
studying it closely thanks to scp-187's
advance warning when exposed to scp-015
a massive network of pipes that seems to
be slowly growing and defends itself
from any attempts to work on it with
tools
scp-187 observed few differences from
its current state until she opened the
door inside she reported a massive
network of pipes Reaching For Miles with
no end in sight
scp-015 had been reduced to a manageable
site and its danger had been contained
but scp-187 indicated that it may be
getting ready for its biggest and most
dangerous expansion yet
scp-415 a seemingly normal human man
with an ability to regenerate his
internal organs has been a subject of
the foundation's investigation since his
arrival particularly due to the strange
physical alterations he underwent to
make it easier to access his organs he's
one of the more peaceful scps at the
foundation but as soon as scp-187 was
exposed to him she became Disturbed she
begged to be removed from the room and
upon interrogation revealed that she saw
scp-415 is a deceased corpse what is
going to happen to the seemingly
Immortal man
scp-187 was also exposed to some of the
more dangerous scps in the foundation
including
SCP-173 a seemingly living statue that
moves in unpredictable ways whenever it
isn't observed and has been responsible
for the deaths of many d-class personnel
who enter its enclosure for cleaning but
it seems to be stable in containment so
why when exposed to it did scp-187 begin
screaming immediately have to be removed
from the enclosure and fall into a
catatonic state for two days she
remembered nothing from the vision she
had of the statue and it took days for
her to recover fully the foundation is
keeping a close eye on the Statue even
closer than they were before
scp-106 also known as the old man had a
brave killer resembling an elderly
rotting corpse is known for its frequent
escapes and sadistic attacks on anyone
near it when exposed to scp-187 the
observation lasted less than a minute
before the old man attempted to escape
scp-187 looked to be in direct Danger
from the old man but he never touched
her or harmed her in any way when she
was interviewed after she explained that
the old man wanted an audience someone
to watch it the incident was recorded as
a close call and an indication that some
of the other entities may have their own
plans for scp-187
scp-187's power Works without fail and
that tempts many people to try to use
her to get answers to important
questions but they should be careful
what they wish for as one doctor found
out during an examination
scp-187 looked at the woman's hand and
observed that it was odd that she wasn't
wearing her wedding ring but the doctor
was and had been for the last 19 years
but the next day her husband filed for
divorce and scp-187's prophecies proved
once again correct
so what are the future plans for scp-187
the foundation is being careful with her
abilities both to preserve her sanity
and to prevent any potential time
paradoxes a routine has been established
to keep her safe fed and protected from
some of the worst effects of her ability
but the experiments using her Visions
aren't going to stop anytime soon many
of her Visions predicted dangerous new
Evolutions in ketter class anomalies
giving the team time to prepare and up
security measures no one knows where
scp-187 came from or what the source of
her unique abilities is but while the
SCP Foundation is keeping some of the
most dangerous entities in the world
safely locked away their most valuable
asset may be one of the most harmless
because as long as scp-187 has her
Visions the next breakout or apocalyptic
event can be stopped in its tracks
before it happens the fabric of our
world is littered with strange doorways
if you know where to look for them tares
portals anomalies all leading to places
and planes Beyond human imagining and
understanding an
scp-2317 otherwise known as a door to
another world certainly fits that
description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards
scp-2317 appears to be a simple and
unsuspecting wooden door in its frame
it hardly looks like it requires such
extreme round-the-clock security or
needs a strange secretive ritual that
the foundation performs presumably to
keep the door closed
but of course sometimes the most
interesting thing about a closed doorway
isn't where it leads it's what it keeps
out
even by the foundation's already high
standards
the requirements and regulations for
personnel who are assigned to scp-2317
seem oddly specific psychological
testing is standard practice to work for
the foundation but an additional hurdle
that anyone has to clear before even
getting to Glimpse at this unassuming
wooden door is having a score of at
least 72 on the Milgram obedience
examination
it is also mandatory that Personnel
assigned to maintaining it are both
unmarried with no children or next of
kin as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and objectives
these may seem like strange requirements
after all
scp-2317 is just a door isn't it
perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about
scp-2317 buried deep under layers upon
layers of security with only the
overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly
still if
scp-2317 is a door to another world an
alternate Dimension or parallel reality
it must be safe enough to visit after
all the foundation has been sending
Personnel in there on a regular basis
daily in fact
according to the o5 council this is done
as part of a procedure to maintain
active containment of
something lurking beyond that old wooden
door frame
but what could possibly warn such
constant maintenance and surveillance
in accordance with the foundation's
guidelines all staff are required to
rotate out of observing scp-2317 after
every two months and spend the following
third month in full psychological
counseling before they are permitted to
return to the containment unit housing
the door to another world
was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly this was the title
given to the Daily containment procedure
that absolutely had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the foundation
he did make one request to his
commanding officer however
he wanted to know what had happened to
the last guard that had performed the
procedure
didn't make it out of psychological
evaluation
the officer replied
not letting this affect his dedication
the guard was told to prepare for
procedure 220 Calabasas
along with a fellow member of foundation
security Personnel the guard was
instructed to gather everything on a
strange list
the first was a pre-selected member of
Class D personnel specifically a
convicted murderer class D refers to
disposable class Personnel Expendable
individuals recruited by the foundation
for the sole purpose of testing scps
class D's were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing and the one
chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told
a foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D's solely as
the assistant from that point on
next the guard collected a live chicken
an obsidian edged knife a silver
asparagalum and aspersorium to be filled
with 500 cc's of holy water that have
been blessed by a priest of the
abrahamic faith and finally a one
kiloton nuclear device which according
to instructions was only to be detonated
in the unlikely events of a catastrophic
containment failure in other words The
Last Resort
after following his instructions to the
letter and without question the guard
and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining and leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
scp-2317s and the nature of procedure
220 Calabasas
the class D joining them wasn't actually
a Class D
the assistant as they were now referred
to was in reality another Foundation
staff member with a level 4 security
clearance specifically tailored to
scp-2317
every member of Staff entering through
scp-2317 and taking an active role in 22
Calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or
treated as a member of disposable class
fighting back the nagging question of
why the foundation would employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world that solar noon when the sun was
highest over scp-2317
solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the foundation
as they entered the old wooden door
Beyond lay a baron salt plane stretching
out for kilometers in every direction
this alternate Dimension according to
the briefing was designated
scp-2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered
each of them bearing intricately
detailed Engravings unlike anything from
any era of ancient history
procedure 220 Calabasas was carried out
quickly but carefully the guard watching
as the celebrant and assistant were
careful not to miss a step
first the celebrant scattered holy water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergulum and aspersorium
looking down at his feet and keeping a
steady Pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them
the guard watched intently as the
celebrant completed his circuit around
the pillars and turned to the assistant
anointing his head with holy water
Seven Seals seven rings
seven Thrones for the Scarlet King he
said aloud
the assistant with the obsidian blade in
his hand took the chicken and dispatched
it in sacrifice
letting its blood mix with the holy
water
he then repeated the celebrant circuit
in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars
blood for the old gods water for the new
king the assistant recited pouring the
remaining mix of blood and holy water
over a patch of salt in the middle of
the Seven Pillars
even though he knew it wasn't his place
to question the foundation as the 220
Calabasas procedure took place the guard
couldn't help but wonder what all this
was for
seems so ritualistic like something
deeply religious or even magical he
never bought into all that occult mumbo
jumbo even while working for the
foundation but he had learned not to
question anything even the strangest and
most inexplicable of sights
little did he know that beneath his feet
was an ancient and unknowable horror a
beast Chained and lying in weight
contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature
humanoid and obese its body covered
entirely in Scales thicker than armor
plating
branch-like horns protruded from its
jawless head pointing up to change that
hung from the Seven Pillars above
each one hooked into the entity's back
all but one of the chains was broken a
final withering shackle keeping the
devour of worlds in its underground
prison
ever since 1894 BCE when origin Mystics
imprisoned it the Devourer has been
waiting patiently for its inevitable
freedom
it knows as well as the foundation that
nothing can be done to prevent the final
chain from one day breaking
even procedure 220 Calabasas won't keep
the creature contained
it's nothing more than a smoke screen an
act designed to create an illusion of
active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent
solution can be devised to keep
scp-2317 imprisoned
of course if the guard had known this it
would have also explained the need for a
one kiloton nuclear device as part of
this stage ritual
procedure 220 Calabasas had all the
components to trick everyone below the
o5 council emulating religious occult
rituals The increased level of security
surrounding the procedure and its
purpose
and telling staff that any failure to
correctly and completely perform the 220
Calabasas procedure will result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario
all these elements work together to
conceal the truth that one day the
Devourer will escape and lay waste to
our dimension
knowledge is power and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly perhaps if the
guard had learned any of this he'd have
understood why his predecessor never
made it out of psychological evaluation
maybe if you had questioned the purpose
of procedure 220 Calabasas he'd have
learned the true nature of scp-2317
and what that doorway kept down
but he was loyal to the foundation
through and through
has the team finished performing 220
Calabasas and returned through the
wooden door the guard took one last
glance over his shoulder at the vast
salt plane
the entire Dimension was calm silent
but not peaceful it was patient The
Entity had waited centuries for its time
and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain
one day the door was closed behind the
guard as he the celebrant the assistant
and his fellow security officers stepped
back through
their work done and as far as they knew
preventing catastrophe for another day
only the foundation higher-ups the
overseer Council are aware of the true
danger posed by
scp-2317 and its sole inhabitant
current predictions are that at some
point within the next 30 Years the
Devourer of Worlds will be freed
any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place
have so far failed as such the o5
council has elected to continue
providing Foundation personnel with the
ignorant hope that procedure 220
Calabasas is an effective strategy for
containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out
in the case of
scp-2317 the unassuming wooden door
holds at Bay an ancient creature of
Untold power
that will one day break free and wreak
havoc in our dimension
nothing the foundation does can prevent
it or keep it contained behind the door
to another world
and only the overseer Council knows that
any and all efforts to do so are futile
with all that in mind we can only hope
that the doorway of
scp-2317 stays closed at least for a
little while longer
it was quiet too quiet that had been
what everyone remembered about that day
ask any member of personnel who was
working what the one thing they were
called before it happened it all tell
you the same that it had been too quiet
and Erie lull and the foundation's usual
day-to-day activity followed by Untold
unspeakable chaos but the quiet had come
first and within that quiet a Madman was
hiding his name was Vince Barrett at
least that was his legal name but he
much preferred to go by his online
moniker of the tainted lizard or just
the zard for short anyone who chooses to
call themselves something like that in
an attempt to sound cool might well be a
person to avoid and in Vince sorry the
zard's case that sentiment was accurate
he was a social recluse devoting a lot
of his time to some of the darker
corners of the internet and we don't
just mean that he spent his days
trolling through Reddit no the zard's
interests were in the Paranormal the
unusual and inexplicable as well as the
community of his fellow internet
recluses dedicated to unearthing the
true Supernatural horrors of the world
eventually spending so much time in
corners of the online world where few
normal people would dare To Tread that
would lead to Zar becoming a member of
the prolific Forum known as parawatch
this was the real deal not just urban
legends and blurry photos of Bigfoot or
Faked handheld videos of people falling
into the back rooms perowatch had long
been known to and kept under the
surveillance of the SCP Foundation why
well because this Infamous online
Message Board would occasionally feature
posts about anomalies some even
including scps and leaked information
about the foundation themselves of
course hardly any of these posts stayed
up for very long before the foundation's
tech team scrubbed them permanently but
it was here on the parawatch Forum where
Vince Barrett would encounter a fateful
video clip acting fast he managed to
save the file before it was taken down
it was footage taken from the body cam
of a foundation security officer during
the midst of a Containment Breach bizard
hit play his hands shaking with
excitement the original poster of the
clip to parawanch had said that this
footage was perhaps the only known video
on the entire fire internet that
depicted something known as
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile of
course those familiar with 682 and the
SCP Foundation will need no introduction
but Vince on the other hand had only
ever heard rumors about this creature
and now in the video playing on his
computer screen he was seeing it for the
first time the reptile was free from its
containment chamber tearing its way
through a foundation facility and making
quick work of dispatching the security
Personnel that dared to stand in its way
it was a force of unbridled Carnage and
rage destroying anything in its path and
adapting to its environment deep in the
parawatch Forum the zard had read rumors
and leaks from alleged x foundation
staff and detractors that 682 was like
something out of a nightmare they said
that the creature could adapt perfectly
in response to damage inflicted upon it
or to changes in its environment as well
as heal any injury it's a attained it
persisted it kept on going and something
about that enamored Vince to the
infamous anomaly he thought it was
beautiful the ultimate apex predator and
admired the hard to destroy reptile's
tenacity as well as its ferocity
watching the horrific Containment Breach
footage he realized then and there that
he was a devoted fanatic of
scp-682 his time on the dark side of the
web had twisted his mind and led him to
make one fateful decision that he needed
to see the creature in person that had
been almost a year earlier and in the
time since the tainted lizard had pulled
on every dark web string he knew of
eventually getting in contact with a
shady group called the chaos Insurgency
Vince had managed to get a hold of a
real life SCP Foundation key card as
well as the location of the facility
they were holding 682 in and a forged
transfer document posing as a humble
unassuming janitor the zard had made his
way in inside the foundation and wasted
no time in making a beeline straight for
the acid tank where 682 was held he
stared at the creature through the glass
eyes wide and jaw slacked in utter awe
of the Monstrous reptile perhaps the
biggest fan of scp-682 on the planet
couldn't quite believe he was standing
in the presence of the creature itself
it barely seemed to pay him any mind
from the other side of the tank the acid
surrounding it melting 682 as fast as it
could heal seeing it in containment in
raged fence he hated that the foundation
had kept what he viewed as a perfect
organism locked up after having tried
time and time again to destroy it don't
worry the zard murmured approaching the
tank well over the minimum safe distance
you're a force of unparalleled
destruction and you don't deserve to be
here I'm gonna set you free
unfortunately after the glass had been
smashed and the alarm screamed out that
another Containment Breach was occurring
Vince would quickly find out that the
reptilian Beast he revered so highly
didn't quite hold him in the same regard
if you thought the zard was going to
make it all the way through the story
alive well then we regret to inform you
that you're sorely mistaken although not
as woefully misguided as Vince himself
who was the first person in the path of
scp-682 when he freed the creature with
all those leaks and rumors on pairwatch
had failed to mention about the heart to
destroy reptile was its vehement and
Relentless hatred for all other forms of
life including its very own fan and the
tainted lizard was only the first
casualty of
scp-682's latest Rampage but this time
was different sure 682 was easily
tearing its way through SCP Foundation
Personnel left and right security teams
were flung aside and ripped to shreds as
they tried in vain to recontain the
Monster research staff found themselves
tripping over each other trying to rush
out of the destructive path of the hard
to destroy reptile only to find
themselves the next to face its
ferocious attack in other words it
seemed to to mostly be another unbridled
Slaughter common fare for an scp-682
Containment Breach except rather than
Breaking its way out of the facility
this particular instance saw the
creature heading in the direction of
another anomaly
scp-914 better known as the Clockworks
now if a rampaging regenerative reptile
on the loose wasn't enough cause for
concern then seeing it moving along its
trajectory to another anomalous
refinement machine certainly was those
that had been on the other side of the
facility when the dearly departed zard
set 682 free we're now looking on in
horror as the hard to destroy reptile
burst into the room housing scp-914 the
foundation staff in the midst of panic
stared at security monitors with baited
breath palpable fear hanging in the air
each and every one of them knew that
scp-682 was more than just a Mindless
Beast the creature was fiercely
frighteningly intelligent sentient even
and as it approached the controls for
the Clockworks every onlooker secretly
hoped something or someone would step in
at the last second and prevent
scp-682 from entering the machine
unfortunately that's not what happened
scp-914 word into life its gears and
Gyros spinning as scp-682 entered the
input booth now normally the way the
Clockworks operates is by destroying any
item placed within it and replacing it
with something else in the output Booth
depending on its setting it either
completely disintegrates an item breaks
down an object into its base components
replaces it with an equivalent or
improves it and being set to very fine
as it was right now
scp-914 can even add anomalous
properties to whatever is put inside of
it but what happens when an
indestructible and infinitely adaptable
monstrosity is in the Clockworks while
it can't destroy and recreate a better
version of something that would be known
for being hard to destroying cannot the
entire machine was going haywire
scp-682 was adapting to the refinement
process refusing to let scp-914 unmake
it even to replace it with an improved
version of itself the hard to destroy
reptile and the Clockworks were at a
momentary stalemate and watched with
baited Breath by the foundation
scp-914 began to malfunction its
Clockwork components getting stuck as if
the machine was jammed its cogs were
clogged up unable to destroy the subject
in the input Booth the room around was
beginning to Shake in fact the very
ground was trembling at the force of the
whole machine shuddering enact the
abandoned all hope protocol the head of
research said desperately watching the
events unfold from the other side of the
building the site director looked at
them and nodded the pair of them
entering their secure passcodes to
activate this secretive security measure
just as they did a small earthquake
erupted underfoot the entire wing of the
facility housing the Clockworks and and
scp-682 had collapsed into the ground a
huge crater was all that remained
littered with wreckage of a whole
portion of the foundation site along
with broken pieces of scp-914 for the
next few minutes everyone was on edge
secretly hoping that scp-682 hadn't
survived maybe the Clockworks had
managed to destroy it but the sheer
force of doing so had caused the machine
to collapse in on itself or perhaps the
hard to destroy reptile was now buried
beneath several thousand tons of debris
dead at long last but the foundation
staff knew better than to get their
hopes up and sure enough just as an
armed security team approached the
crater something started stirring in the
rubble suddenly
scp-682 came bursting out of the crater
emerging in not quite the same state
although no less deadly than before the
Clockworks hadn't been able to unmake
the hard to destroy reptile but the
resultant malfunction and explosion had
imbued the creature with a whole host of
of new anomalous abilities it still
resembled its old self but was now more
humanoid standing by petal instead of on
all fours some of its body mass had
seemingly been reduced due to damage
sustained in the malfunction although
scp-682 was still plenty of feet taller
than an ordinary human being in fact it
could be any height it needed to be the
creature scaly skin seemed to be
shifting unnaturally moving of its own
accord like it was already preparing to
adapt to oncoming damage and as the
nearby security team were about to find
out this made it even deadlier than
before in a panic the foundation
officers opened fire only to find that
their weapons weren't operating the way
they should something caused excitation
of the copper shells of their bullets
making them either expand and block the
barrels of their guns or causing them to
backfire horribly injuring the security
Personnel wielding them before anybody
could even call an air support or heavy
artillery as a backup a number of the
foundation most powerful weapons
suffered even more catastrophic misfires
missiles detonated early they hadn't
even been aimed at scp-682 yet but they
would have been instead they exploded
taking with them a huge number of
foundation entities some miles away from
where the newly refined reptile now
stood
scp-682's regenerative Powers had been
altered by the Clockworks it wasn't
purely reactive to oncoming damage now
it was preemptive it could adapt to
attacks that hadn't even happened yet
with no way of stopping it
scp-682 began decimating everything in
its path with greater ferocity than ever
over the coming days the newly dubbed
impossible to destroy reptile began its
biggest Rampage yet entering a permanent
rage State and unleashing destruction on
a global scale it stormed through cities
and wiped out entire major population
centers in moments it seemed nothing on
Earth could stand against the refined
reptile fueled by by its singular
mission to wipe out all life in
existence the surviving Personnel of the
SCP Foundation soon came to learn that
no damage could be inflicted on the
creature whatsoever
scp-682 could predict attacks ahead of
the person that would carry it out and
then adapt changing the very world
around it so that attack never came the
impossible to destroy reptile's
adaptations usually took the form of
diverting any oncoming damage it
preempted it would take and instead
inflicted that same damage on whoever it
chose even though the machine had
malfunctioned the Clockworks had made
scp-682 that good at adapting to its
surroundings that the creature had
almost become a universal constant the
fact that it could not be harmed now
seemed to be as fundamental of a law as
that of gravity but that wasn't going to
stop the SCP Foundation from trying the
number of casualties the world over had
been increasing steadily day by day as
scp-682 continued its devastating
campaign of Slaughter some of the
remaining scraps of the foundation had
tried to subdue the creature but in the
attempts at fighting it with
Conventional Weapons were ill-advised to
say the least after all how do you fight
against a creature that can predict your
every move and counter them before
you've even thought of those moves well
you can try throwing something so
unexpected at it at least pulling
something out of left field means that
the chances of scp-682 seeing it coming
are slightly Slimmer and that was where
the abandoned all hope protocol came in
you see the foundation had been
anticipating that 682 Would One Day
become too powerful to contain long
before the creature had gained its new
ability to preemptively adapt and while
the worldwide death toll had climbed
from hundreds of thousands of innocent
people to the earliest Millions an
unlikely counter-attack was brewing one
so unexpected that even the impossible
to destroy reptile would struggle to see
it coming just as Humanity was facing
the brink of Extinction the foundation
dispatched their last hope at stopping
scp-682 other scps the abandon all hope
protocol had been devised for when the
suffering and destruction caused by
scp-682 became so great that there were
no other options left when it had been
activated Foundation agents stationed at
various sites across the world had
gathered a specially selected group of
anomalies each one was chosen because
they were known to be sympathetic
towards Humanity or at least be coerced
into taking on
scp-682 and now these scps were stepping
up to the plate ready to fight the
impossible to destroy reptile or more
likely to die trying
scp-076-2 the immortal Warrior known as
able was Infamous for picking fights the
ancient Sumerian swordsman had a
penchant for seeking out the most
challenging adversaries so convincing
him to take a crack at SCP 682 wasn't
all that difficult however rushing into
battle against the refined reptile Abel
quickly found he couldn't draw his
weapons from his pocket Dimension they
were dissipating the moment his fingers
touched them Vanishing faster than he
could draw no matter the warrior thought
he'd been alive for centuries and thus
had become a master in every form of
hand-to-hand combat as you can imagine
he didn't last very long left to slowly
revive inside his Stone tomb after
scp-682 had finished dispatching him
Abel's brother Kane incurred a slightly
different result when he went Toe to Toe
with the impossible to destroy reptile
scp-073 was hardly the fighter his
brother was but had the anomalous trait
of reflecting incoming damage back at
whoever was inflicting it on him so when
scp-682 attacked Kane theoretically the
same attack would have bounced back and
harmed the reptile itself and before
that's what would have happened but now
scp-682 could adapt preemptively a
strange never before seen phenomenon
occurred it appeared that neither
scp-073 nor the refined reptile were
harming each other at all however on a
metaphysical level the potential damage
of 682's attacks against Kane were being
reflected back towards the reptile only
for the creature to preemptively adapt
to the damage from its own attack being
inflicted back what resulted was a
feedback loop of Perpetual possible
damage that ended only when Kane
eventually passed out from shock
unfortunately while he could reflect
damage back at an attacker he felt the
pain of every hit and scp-682 had more
than just a mean right hook the
foundation had hoped given its 100
mortality record that scp-096 would have
no trouble killing the impossible to
destroy reptile or at the very least
harming it enough so that it could be
subdued after all 682 still needed to
see and anyone looking at the shotgun
quickly met their end but when the tall
pale humanoid approached scp-682
something unusual happened the reptile
could look at scp-096 able to see it
perfectly perhaps the creature's
adaptive properties were creating an
intentional blind spot in its Vision
removing scp-096 from view or maybe 682
no longer saw with just eyes perceiving
the world in a manner far beyond our
understanding of basic sight but
whatever the case the impossible to
destroy reptile made scp-096 turn and
flee in Terror compelled to put an end
to the reptile's reign of terror
scp-4494 the Specter manifested nearby
and tried to intervene the result was
nothing short of brutal a one-sided
fight that not even the living
embodiment of crime fighting could hope
to win after scp-682 had finished off
the Specter a strange black fluid began
oozing from nearby although one of the
hardest to Wrangle the foundation
believed believed that they had
convinced scp-106 to Aid in taking down
scp-682 the old man emerged from the
oily secretion shuffling menacingly
towards the impossible to destroy
reptile it seemed to freeze as if it was
taking a defensive stance against the
old man either that or tricking him into
getting closer before he could even
reach out a decrepit hand to touch the
reptile's shifting skin
scp-106 was suddenly coated in copious
amounts of the black substance he
secreted it coded him like thick tar the
more his decaying body produced the more
he was covered in it normally he was
resistant to the corrosive burning
effects of this substance however
scp-682's preemptive adaptation Powers
had caused scp-106 to overproduce the
oily substance enough to rapidly
dissolve the old man into a steaming
black puddle it was at this point that
scp-343 colloquially known as God
lowered his newspaper paper and looked
out of his window that is to say he
looked out of the huge hole that had
been left in the wall of his cell being
omniscient as cp343 was already burdened
with the awareness of what had happened
scp-682 had been refined into an even
worse version of itself by the
Clockworks up until now God had been
happy to avoid all the fighting and just
see how everything worked out but as
much as he tried to distract himself
scp-682 slaughtering other scps and
droves was getting in the way of his
reading oh this again in the Split
Second the entire universe had been
unmade and then remade Almost exactly
the same except scp-343 had made a
slight adjustment giving a little nudge
to cause and effect in a few places as a
result a certain misguided form user had
never and would never infiltrate the
foundation and break
scp-682 free leading to the hard to
destroy reptile being refined by the
Clockworks although while it had been
unceremoniously returned to its original
form and placed back in its acid tank
scp-682 could still remember the power
it had wielded only moments before
everything had been Rewritten all it
needed was another chance to get into
the Clockworks ever since she was in
high school Faith had dreamed of moving
out and finally getting a place of her
own it wasn't that she didn't love her
parents she did but they were always
around always coming into her room
without knocking telling her when to go
to bed when to wake up not to eat dinner
in front of the TV in college she had
some welcome Independence but she had to
live with roommates again they were
perfectly nice people some of them she
even considered good friends but she
hated having to share her space having
to come home from a long day of classes
and see someone else's dishes piled up
in the sink to have someone else's music
keeping her awake at night to delay her
morning shower because someone else had
gotten their fur
so she was thrilled when a few years
after graduating she got a new job at a
marketing company that would finally let
her afford a place by herself at last
she could have some peace some quiet and
most importantly some privacy Faith
spent all day moving furniture and
unpacking boxes turning the little
apartment into a real home it wasn't
much just a main room she used as a
bedroom and living room a bathroom and a
basic little kitchen but it was all hers
and all of the little personal touches
she'd put together really made it feel
like the place was meant for her there
was the orange couch she picked up at a
vintage store downtown the coffee table
she'd gotten for free from her last
roommate bring pictures of her family
and friends a bed with Linens in her
favorite color light blue and lots and
lots of potted plants over time she
would find even more things more little
personal touches to liven up the space
now how to decide celebrate her new home
her gas wasn't on yet so she couldn't
cook anything but that was the perfect
excuse to order in 30 minutes or less
later she was kicking back on her couch
with a large cheese pizza watching a
scary movie on her TV no one would ask
to switch it over to the bachelor no one
would take the last slice while she was
in the bathroom it was perfect finally A
Little Piece of Heaven an introvert's
Paradise as she finished her first meal
in the new place she felt her eyes
beginning to grow heavy the day of
strenuous unpacking catching up with her
body just as she was thinking about
calling it a night a pale-faced monster
appeared out of nowhere on screen
terrifying the movie's main character
and making Faith jump spilling her soda
all over the coffee table damn it she
groaned already she'd made a mess but
hey she tried to look on the bright side
it was yet another first to break in the
apartment she grabbed a kitchen towel
mop up the soda and when she returned to
the main room she froze there was
something in the window standing out
against the darkness outside at first
she thought it was a reflection a trick
of the light but as she slowly
approached the window eyes wide and
hands trembling she got a better look
there was a face a little difficult to
make out as if it were peering Out of
the Shadows but unmistakable nonetheless
it was pale humid vaguely resembling a
strange man with dark circles under his
eyes and he was looking right at her she
didn't scream she was too terrified to
make a sound she stared at the face for
a long moment waiting for it to do
something anything after several moments
of the tenses staring contest of her
life she blinked the face didn't budge
ye you need to leave she finally spoke
surprising herself as she did if you
don't get out of here I'm calling the
cops again the face did nothing do you
hear me her voice climbed in Pitch her
heart pounding against the inside of her
chest who was he what did he want she
became vaguely aware of the fact that
she couldn't see the rest of the man's
body just his face looking at her with a
neutral expression a look of vague
curiosity like someone watching a caged
animal at the zoo might have it was then
she remembered something that made her
blood run cold made the towel drop from
her hands as her stomach tank she lived
on the third floor her apartment had no
balcony no fire escape he could have
climbed up whatever was looking at her
through her window it was no ordinary
peeping Tom she couldn't say how long
she stared at the face its unblinking
eyes it's inscrutable expression she
moved closer to the window step by step
until she was almost nose to nose with
the thing she couldn't think of it as a
person though it looked like one mostly
she should run screaming out the door
looking for some kind of help but what
would she say but there was a floating
face looking at her through the window
what if it was somehow all in her head
some sort of hallucination brought on by
exhaustion and the stress of the move
she raised a fist and following a
passive Instinct wrapped on the glass
she didn't know what she expected for it
to Blink to move to knock back to say
something but nothing happened it just
stayed there as if it were part of the
window itself Faith pulled the curtains
closed hiding the strange face from view
with any luck it would be gone in the
morning she had worked hard to get this
apartment and she would be damned if she
let some strange thing whatever it was
drive her out of her new home but as she
climbed into bed and pulled the covers
up to her chin she could still feel its
Gaze on her as if it could see through
the thick fabric of the curtains she
rolled over onto her side her back to
the window and tried her best to forget
about it to shake that horrible feeling
of being observed she lay there for
hours eyes open heart racing but finally
the exhaustion one and she Slipped Away
into sleep she didn't dream at all that
night it was as if she closed her eyes
and seconds later it was morning she
woke to the beep of her alarm feeling as
if she hadn't rested at all the first
thing she did was climb out of the bed
and go to the window carefully
tentatively she opened the curtains she
let out a sigh of deep relief face was
gone she must have imagined it after all
a bit concerning but as long as it
didn't happen again she wouldn't have
anything to worry about lack of sleep
does strange things to the mind after
all no longer plagues by the fear of
that strange face faith hopped into the
shower and let the worries of the
previous night wash away disappearing
down the drain she brushed her teeth
dried her hair did her makeup and
dressed for work after a banana and a
quick cup of coffee she was out the door
work was exceptionally busy that day and
it pushed any memory of the Oddity in
the window out of her mind entirely she
was even feeling good enough to accept
her friend's offer to grab a drink after
work they met up at a bar down the
street from her new place sharing
cocktails memories and a plate of onion
rings it was a perfect lovely evening by
the time she got home savoring the click
of the key in the lock as she let
herself into her quiet little Sanctuary
she had completely forgotten about the
unusual Apparition she swung the door
open and rushed to dump herself onto the
couch for a bit of TV before bed then
out of the corner of her eye she saw it
the face back in its previous Place
staring at her from the darkness outside
she gaffed at the sight her screamed
catching in her throat it was just as
she remembered it right no something was
different what was it she clapped her
mouth in horror as she identified the
change its expression was different gong
was the vaguely interested neutral
expression now it was smiling at her not
a pleasant smile not a warm friendly
smile a wicked smile twisted and cruel
it knew she was afraid but she'd been
hoping it was gone forever and it was
enjoying itself her hands were shaking
nervous sweat beating on her brow what
do you want from me she whispered
staring into its eyes they didn't move
but they glittered with malicious Glee
just the same what do you want from me
repeated her voice rising to a shout
shut up her next door neighbor yelled
banging on the wall it's after midnight
she couldn't bring herself to respond
she had more important things to attend
to her stomach turned bile rising in her
throat with the face begun again in the
morning would it come back again at
night was the apartment haunted
possessed by a specter doomed to reside
in her window forever was that why the
rent had been so affordable or maybe it
was her maybe this thing had been drawn
to her or maybe she was losing her mind
an accustomed to living alone and her
sanity was slipping away she shivered at
the thought what was worse if the face
was on her head or if it wasn't rather
than attempt to answer the question
gnawing at her she closed the curtains
out of sight out of mind she thought she
would have to keep the curtain closed
possibly forever it was better than
seeing that damned face grinning that
horrible grin but as she tried to settle
in for another rest last night she could
feel its eyes boring into her burning
into her skull she had never felt so
uneasy before she prepared for
cockroaches for black mold and for
burglars but not for this this was
something outside of her understanding
outside of reality itself just don't
look she whispered to herself just don't
look at it it became part of her daily
routine wake up ignore the window go to
work try to forget about the window get
home try desperately not to think about
the window she could always feel it
though as soon as the sun went down
though she kept the curtains closed she
knew there she thought about checking to
see what face it was making this time
but she couldn't bring herself to look
gradually her condition worsened she
woke up to a tightness in her chest
panic attacks that wrecked her body and
felt like her heart might stop beating
her stomach would ache she struggled to
keep food down one morning she rushed to
the bathroom and spat up blood the
effect began to follow her out of the
apartment too far away from the faces
dwelling she would sit at her desk
struggling to focus on marketing
campaigns and pitches and she would feel
a sudden pain in her stomach forcing her
to double over and groan with Agony she
would see flickers of the pale face in
her peripheral vision turning to look
only to find there was nothing there
when she walked down the hall to the
elevator or down the street outside her
building she would feel as if someone
was following her she never saw anyone
never heard any footsteps coming up
behind her but she could never shake off
the sensation soon even her formerly
dreamless nights of sleep has fitful as
they had been became unsafe she would
toss and turn sweating through her
sheets as her subconscious was tormented
by chilling visions and terrible
nightmares she would dream of walking
down a long dark hallway that seemed to
go on forever and something coming up
behind her trying to grab her and drag
her away it would chase her wide dark
eyes and long long limbs grasping at her
as she ran and ran but never escaped
other times she would dream of being
locked in a damp basement chained to a
wall as the pale creature sat in a chair
across from her just watching waiting
for something though she didn't know
what every night another nightmare that
made her wake up screaming fighting off
invisible attackers after two weeks of
living in hell she decided to look out
the window again she had to see had to
know that night when she opened the
curtains it was there mouth wide open
eyes glinting it was laughing at her
screw the deposit enough was enough she
wanted her home back she picked up the
heavy lamp on her bedside table wounded
up and threw it out the window with all
her might the glass shattered little
crystalline Shard sprang in every
direction as the lamp flew through the
air out the window and down to the
street below and just like that the face
was gone she checked every other window
in place the little one in the bathroom
the people on her door but it was
nowhere to be found she was free her
knees gave out and she collapsed to the
floor her face in her hands and wept
from sheer relief tomorrow she would
clean up the broken glass and spin her
landlord a story about a freak accident
someone would come to fix the window and
it would be the best money she had ever
spent eventually the whole ordeal would
fade away from memory like a bad dream
but somewhere out there someone else was
living the nightmare all over again
looking out to darkened window to see an
unwelcome Guest The Entity known as
scp-965
scp-965 is a phenomenon affecting
when it appears it manifests in the
shape of a shadowy face belonging to a
pale man staring in through the window
the details of the man's face vary from
person to person as well as his apparent
age and the direction he is facing
however all reports point to the same
figure at various ages ranging from 10
to 55. the foundation has attempted to
use facial recognition software to
identify a citizen matching the
description of this figure but so far no
one has been found
scp-965 will not appear in just any
window it will only manifest when the
lighting on the outside of the window
drops below illumination of five
candalas the lighting on the inside of
the window does not have any measurable
effect the face will only appear in the
confines of a completely assembled
window frame though the window does not
necessarily need to be installed
anywhere it will only move from one
glass pane to another if its original
point of manifestation is destroyed the
face can be seen from an outside vantage
point though it has been grind by
observers as looking away into the room
when scp-965 first appears to someone it
produces feelings of unease anxiety and
low-grade paranoia anyone within the
visual range of the affected window will
experience these feelings even if the
window is covered by curtains or any
other means any individual that sleeps
in an area visible to
scp-965's manifestation point will begin
to experience difficulty sleeping
suffering from upsetting and disturbing
dreams however this is not the endpoint
of the entity's impact on those it
appears to at a point between 3 and 10
nights of sleep after its initial
appearance the entities facial
expression will begin to shift into a
noticeable smile after the shift the
victim's symptoms will become physical
as well as mental including ulcers and
intestinal bleeding heartburn abdominal
pain and even vomiting blood this has
been attributed to the entity's
influence on the human body's reaction
to heightened levels of stress and fear
the subjects that reach this stage of
exposure to scp-965 begin to see its
face in Windows in their dreams as well
as spotting it in their peripheral
vision while going about their Waking
Life they begin to see the face out of
the corner of their eye even when the
affected window is nowhere in sight
these additional sightings are
accompanied by lingering feelings of
paranoia and The Sensation that
something is following or watching them
though the entity has never made a sound
and does not move while it is visible it
can disappear and reappear in different
poses it has also displayed notable
signs of sentience appearing
disappointed when it manifests in an
empty room and angry if it sees someone
who broke its previous window when
presented with one of the agents who
first brought it into custody The Entity
appeared frightened for the first time
testing involving
scp-965 involving the destruction of its
host window confirmed that a multi-paned
window might act as multiple holding
zones but significant damage to its
overall structure keeps it from being a
viable replacement in this particular
case the entity manifested in a nearby
experimentation Chambers observation
window which was promptly destroyed in
order to prevent any potential breaches
for a month following this incident The
Entity manifested with noticeably
hostile facial expressions clearly
resentful of its treatment only one
other notable incident has occurred so
far during the course of
scp-965's containment by the SCP
Foundation Dr Al the rest of her name
has been redacted from the official file
was the head researcher assigned to
scp-965 for several months before she
filed an official request for transfer
to a different test subject she was
beginning to experience intrusive
visions of scp-965 and lingering
feelings of paranoia lasting long after
she left the foundation signed her
symptoms were consistent with those of
someone who had slept in the presence of
the entity though she swore up and down
she had never napped or slept at all in
the vicinity of the affected window she
was temporarily relieved of her duties
and provided with psychological care so
far no other instances of scp-965
impacting staff who have not slept in
its presence have been reported but this
case set an unsettling precedent the
mental health of anyone assigned to
scp-965 is to be strictly monitored in
case it expands its influence again
scp-965 is contained within a framed
ready to install window made up of six
panes of clear glass or other comparable
material at a size of at least 15
centimeters by 30 centimeters the window
must be kept in an environmentally
controlled storage facility capable of
withstanding earthquakes and other
seismic activity the window must be
inspected at least once a week in order
to check the Integrity of the material
additionally at least two identical
framed windows must be stored in the
same facility in separate Chambers with
additional insulation any Lighting in
the containment chamber should be kept
at a minimum of 100 30 Candelas at any
time Personnel are inside with the
exception of research and
experimentation though scp-965 is
currently contained the foundation is
unable to control its movement should
its current window be destroyed
therefore scp-965 is classified as
Euclid scopeup phobia is the fear of
being watched or looked at by others
those suffering from this fear will
often avoid Windows terrified of who
might be standing on the other side
staring in and keeping track of
everything they do even those of us
without scopophobia might find ourselves
feeling a prickle of dread while looking
out the window at night watching for a
shadowy figure or a ghastly face pressed
to the glass most of the time of course
there is no one there it's just an
overactive imagination the lingering
effect of watching one too many scary
movies but eventually your luck might
just run out one night when the world
Falls quiet and you go to close the
curtains before you go to sleep just in
in case you might just feel that someone
is right there on the other side of that
thin pane of glass staring at you with
wide unblinking eyes it won't ever come
inside but it isn't going anywhere and
as long as you are where it can see you
you will never know peace again
true horror the airplane door belching
smoke and a burning red light the dead
talking and ancient guttural Latin a
monstrous Angel made of rings wings and
eyes whipping barbs tentacles and
screaming terrified priests you can
scarcely imagine a more hellish Place
Bishop Franklin's knees gave out under
him as soon as the man set foot back on
Solid Ground nearing his 70th birthday
he'd never been a particularly tough man
but after the day he'd had he doubted
he'd ever be the same again almost being
whipped into another dimension almost
being at the center of a nuclear
explosion seeing he threw up on the
ground as the foundation Personnel
rushed over to him never never again
just eight hours earlier Bishop Franklin
had been getting on with his Friday
preparations they had Mass coming up
this weekend so he was doing the rounds
of the cathedral putting out new candles
and straightening pews he was nearly
done ready to get on with the rest of
his morning when he saw two suited
figures entering the cathedral he
shuffled over to them trying to explain
that they were closed but quickly
faltered when he saw the grave look on
their faces just 10 minutes later he was
in the back of their car still holding a
spare candle with Agents from the SCP
Foundation sitting on either side of him
they handed him file after file each
most redacted explaining the basis of
who they were and where they were headed
it was a lot for the old priest to wrap
his head around he'd always believed in
a higher power and a spiritual realm but
this sounded a whole lot more serious
than that monsters aliens other
dimensions facilities portals he
questioned agents on it they just look
grimly from one to another as the car
wound its way to the private airstrip in
the middle of nowhere Bishop Franklin
had always hated flying but he hated it
a whole lot more as he approached the
airplane with no idea where he'd be
landing a small group of men were
gathered on the runway just by the foot
of a Boeing aircraft it seemed like a
pretty substantial plane for such a
small group of them he was at least a
little heartened to see that none of
them had brought luggage either in fact
most of them were just like him as
Bishop Franklin approached the group he
recognized various faces other Bishops
archbishops and Senior priests with him
there they totaled seven the others all
looked at him not saying much Bishop
Franklin tried his best to start asking
questions the two things happened in
quick succession that closed his mouth
very quickly firstly the luggage hold of
the plane was opened and two enormous
shapes were loaded into it via forklift
each shape had unmistakable symbols on
the sheets covering them nuclear danger
reeling from this Revelation Bishop
Franklin turned to the group to be face
to face with the Pope himself he
immediately shut his mouth you may also
be wondering what on Earth was going on
at this Airfield the truth is Bishop
Franklin along with six other Priests of
abrahamic faiths were about to embark on
the monthly flight of
scp-616 within this plane as all these
men were soon about to find out exists
an emergency door covered with satanic
iconography this door when opened at
ground level operates just like any
other emergency door leading to the
outside of the plane although any
individuals who had passed through this
door in this normal State reported
feeling heightened anxiety during and
after however once a month this door
will be anything but normal opening a
gate to well you'll soon see in order to
mitigate the threat posed to humanity
through
scp-616-1 or the gate the plane must be
in the air at the time of its opening
far above and away from any human
settlements in order to keep this event
contained the door must be kept open for
the duration of the Portal's existence
until it has closed of its own accord
but holding this door open is not a
simple test of strength it is a test of
belief in order to protect all of
humanity from unknown horrors of a
cataclysmic scale seven Priests of
abrahamic Fates must be on board for
this monthly flight praying for the door
to remain open the ability to keep the
door open it turns out is unrelated to
physical prowess but instead is based
entirely on one's own belief that the
door can be held open as such religious
figures praying to a higher power are
incredibly well suited to the task once
per year the flight is blessed by the
pope and every time the plane takes off
it must be holding two nuclear warheads
in its Hull both can be remotely
detonated by the ground team who will be
in constant radio communication with the
pilot should the pilot fail to give them
regular updates on the status of
scp-616-1 the event will be treated as
an XK Class end of the world scenario
and both nuclear devices will be
detonated without hesitation but Bishop
Franklin only knew about half of this
information from his redacted set of
documents and had forgotten half of them
on his stressful car Journey as he
strapped himself into a window seat he
was trembling like a leaf he desperately
wanted to complain about being put into
the situation but he wasn't entirely
sure who he would complain to if he
spoke to anyone external about what he
was about to witness he had been told by
the foundation agents that he would be
administered with a Class C amnestic
whatever that meant he really didn't
want to find out fortunately for him the
most familiar of the faces from the
group of priests sat next to him in the
aisle seat Bishop what was his name
sensing Bishop Franklin's uncertainty
the man reached a Handover and warmly
reintroduced himself Bishop Pete they'd
met two years ago in Berlin just that
small action was almost enough to settle
Bishop Franklin's nerves as the plane
started to barrel down the runway almost
the plane took off causing the old man's
stomach to drop heart hammering he
looked around spotting the emergency
door it was just up ahead of him around
the middle of the fuselage it would have
looked like a normal emergency exit but
for the blood red markings scrawled
across it a wave of dread washed over
him it certainly looked evil that was
for sure trying his best to help Bishop
Pete struck up a conversation he
explained it wasn't his first time doing
this he'd been drafted to help three
months ago it was scary for sure but
everything was totally fine the
foundation had planned everything to a t
it would have helped Bishop Franklin's
nerves but it only made his mind jump to
the nuclear weapons he'd seen loaded
into where his suitcase would have
normally gone the two of them lapsed
into silence for a while no one on the
plane was really speaking he supposed he
should have used this opportunity to
pray but according to his briefing he'd
be doing a lot of that very soon he
hadn't entirely understood what the
foundation had meant by that he'd been
told to pray to quote keep the door open
what had they meant by that a bang
shattered the silence as the emergency
door slammed wide open in an instant the
plane went into a nosedive as all the
air rushed from inside the lights went
out for several seconds then came back
on in flashing panicked spasms Bishop
Franklin clung for dear life onto the
back of the chair in front of him as the
Roar of air rushed around him it had
gone dark outside with shapeless clouds
swirling around him shaking the plane
screaming voices filled the aircraft not
just the voices of the men on board but
women and children too crying out in
agony and Terror through throats that
sounded like they'd been lashed with
razor wire then he saw it
scp-616-1 the gate was wide open smoke
billowed out of it crawling along the
floors of the cabin like an octopus
creeping its way along the ocean floor
red lights seemed to spill out of it but
when he tried to look through the gate
itself it was like his brain wasn't
working anymore there were colors there
but there were ones he didn't recognize
maybe they weren't colors at all it was
like his brain fixated on trying to sort
them into something that made sense
something rational a hand grasped his
arm and he turned to Sea Bishop Pete
staring at him with wild eyes the plane
was going down they could both feel it
and that emergency door was slowly
creeping shut they had been brought onto
this plane for one job only to pray like
their lives depended on it Bishop
Franklin screwed his eyes shut and
clasped his hands together he hadn't
prayed like that since he was a little
kid but he figured now was the time to
use all the tricks in the book he begged
and pleaded in a tiny voice for God to
keep that door open it felt so
counterintuitive so backwards to want to
keep that kind of door open as the air
roared and screamed around him but a
small voice inside of him told him to
persevere have a little faith but
suddenly the bishop noticed that the man
sitting alongside him had fallen silent
feeling like a naughty child at Mass he
opened one eye and peered sideways
Bishop Pete was still in his seat but
he'd slumped over he wasn't breathing
his skin was cold to the touch deathly
cold then all of a sudden his head
rocket backwards and he started talking
not talking like a normal man but
talking like a man possessed his dead
eyes rolled around in his head aimlessly
as guttural voices rasped out of his
throat none of them were the words that
Bishop Franklin recognized they sounded
almost like Latin but far darker and
more ancient and the more the dead man
spoke the more the emergency door closed
the bishop started praying again much
harder than time digging his fingernails
into his palm so hard that he felt them
drawing blood he
to keep this door open he had to and he
could he believed it entirely in that
moment the door banged back open wider
than ever despite the chanting of the
dead body in the seat next to him
nightmare swelled to the Forefront of
his mind as the plane hurtled to the
ground only the plane wasn't hurtling to
the ground in fact it was flying at a
perfectly steady altitude of 10 972
meters with an airspeed of about 780
kilometers an hour in fact aside from
the death of Bishop Pete everything
within the plane was going perfectly to
plan deaths of priests were just an
occupational hazard of keeping this SCP
contained the pilot at the front of the
plane regarded the whole situation
playing out behind him while feeding
constant information back to base
everything was going perfectly according
to plan until the angel appeared Bishop
Franklin wasn't the first one to see it
that was the unfortunate lot of
Archbishop Michael who was sitting
closest to the emergency door he first
spotted while staring through into the
void but his screams of Terror warning
those around him were drowned out by all
the other commotion it was only when the
angel's wings crept their way through
the edges of the door and the creature
LED itself into the cabin that the
others saw it but by this point it was
too late for Archbishop Michael the
angel was not like the angels we see in
pop culture a tall blonde person with
white robes fluffy wings and a gentle
face it was a shifting mass of eyes and
tortured Wings partially crawling along
the ground partially floating under the
weight of its massive frame it had to
squeeze itself through the door to fit
into the plane but as it did it lashed
out at the Archbishop with a sinewy
tendril and got to work violently
killing him that was when Bishop
Franklin sought and began to panic he
wanted nothing more than to stop praying
to let the emergency door slam shut and
keep this creature away from them but
that little voice inside his head told
him that wouldn't work if that door was
allowed to close before the gate had
then it would cause the apocalypse he
could not have that blood on his hands
so he prayed swept pouring down his face
as the angel forced its way through the
gate and into the cabin he prayed as it
slumped across the aisles working its
way along the line of men slaughtering
them one by one he prayed as it saw him
and Rose to its full height unfurling
great wings and readying itself for the
kill and he prayed as a win more
powerful than any on Earth blew through
the cabin and pulled the angel back
through the gate the emergency door
slammed shut and in an instant the plane
seemed to ride itself no more turbulence
no more wind the light flickered once
more and then came back on steadily the
seat belt sign pinged off and oxygen
masks dropped from the ceiling about
four hours too late Bishop Franklin
couldn't believe the time when he looked
at his wristwatch he had been on this
plane for weeks surely not just for
hours that was absurd it all felt like a
dream as the aircraft circled around the
airstrip preparing for landing
everything in the plane seemed totally
normal to him now except of course for
the four dead bodies one of which was
slumped towards him in the aisle seat
the plane landed the bishop staggered
down the stairs and threw up on the
blacktop after a few awkward moments the
pilots sidled over to him and muttered a
quick thanks I was really close to
calling it a failure there and having to
set off them nukes I don't know what you
prayed for but you did good today Bishop
Franklin didn't feel like he did good he
felt like he'd had his whole life his
whole world view turned upside down in
the space of an interstate flight he had
been moments away from either being
vaporized by a nuclear bomb or from
having economy seats to the premiere of
the destruction of the World As We Knew
It but just 31 days later Bishop
Franklin was on that same flight again
praying his hardest as the aircraft
dropped into Free Fall if there was one
thing that the foundation noticed about
working with religious leaders it was
that they had a real determination to
keep coming back to help keep the world
safe but the foundation didn't have the
heart to tell them was that all of the
satanic markings on the door were
actually fake they had been added by
researchers in an attempt to make
scp-616-1 carry more significance for
those in the aircraft later testing
revealed that it was not exclusive to
abrahamic Fates or any faith groups for
that matter that they could keep the
gate open anyone who believed they could
do it was capable of it Faith leaders
however are still being utilized and the
blessing is still being performed by the
pope on a yearly basis it had been found
that these external rituals will not
necessarily directly impactful have
strengthened the belief and resolve of
those inside the plane yielding fewer
casual and shorter durations various
experiments have been conducted to see
beyond the Event Horizon of the gate to
see what's on the other side those in
the plane have reported as having the
name Paradise despite never going inside
a remote controlled Rover was sent
inside the gate on one experiment but
the footage was deemed far too dangerous
as all those who witnessed it died
within two months hopefully you didn't
peer too closely into the gate as you
watched this video those who have
studied the various anomalies contained
by the SCP Foundation know that this
world has quite a lot to fear enormous
World devouring monsters that thrive on
an endless stream of hate seemingly
innocuous statues waiting to snap your
neck the second you turn your back and a
shark-eyed old man with the power to
reach through solid concrete grab hold
of you with his rotting hands and drag
you into his own personal hell
scp-106 can pop into our world whenever
he
but like many of the most efficient
Predators he has his own designated Lair
a pocket Dimension where he can pull his
prey and trap them in a horrifying game
of cat and mouse that only ever ends one
way in a painful prolonged end we all
know what scp-106 uses is pocket
dimension for but what if some of the
other anomalies that the foundation had
a pocket dimension of their very own a
tiny parallel reality that they could
shape in their image and use it for
whatever they wanted what might that
look like a special team of SCP
Foundation operatives were tasked with
conducting an experiment using an
elaborate computer system to run
simulations and see what different
anomalies might do with their pocket
Dimensions should the opportunity ever
arise stranger things have certainly
happened at the SCP Foundation so they
prepared a list of anomalies that
presented the most potential for
interesting findings and fired up the
simulation for the very first subject
effect they selected an anomaly who was
also a colleague Dr bright and
scp-963 the monitor attached to the
computer running the simulation showed a
curious surprising picture there was a
door with one sign bright council
meeting inside past the door was a long
conference table packed to the brim with
different attendees the regards d-class
scientists men and women all wearing the
trademark anomalous amulet it was every
single incarnation of the doctor himself
all talking over each other with great
enthusiasm at the head of the table
there was a monitor depicting the
current incarnation of Dr bright going
about his daily life on a live video
feed all of the many many Dr brytes were
instructing him giving him advice and
guidance on every impulse and decision
some Dr brights were brandishing pies
others chainsaws and others were drawing
schematics for laser guns and catapults
the Council of brytes was working
together other devising pranks schemes
and general Tom Foolery the research
team all agreed that Dr bright could
never learn about this simulation result
lest he tried to recreate it himself
next they inputted details about
scp-1594 Miss Jay's Wiz Kids Schoolhouse
the anomalous computer program capable
of teaching anyone about any subject
with a triumphant beep the computer
announced that it had rendered a
simulation of what Miss Jay's pocket
Dimension might be it was a classroom
decorated in bright colors and cutouts
of various numbers and letters on the
wall motivational portraits were
displayed including kittens grabbing
onto the rungs of a ladder with the
slogan hang in there there were
bookshelves all along the walls filled
to the brim with books at the chalkboard
a three-dimensional version of Miss Jay
herself was standing with her signature
ponytail and bright green vest a piece
of chalk in her hand the desks were all
empty but she had a chipper smile on her
face and was waiting for students to
come in and learn at any minute on the
board she had written welcome class next
they chose an entity whose inner life
was a bit more difficult to discern
whose motivations though seemingly
straightforward were perplexing
scp-049 the Plant Doctor forever in
pursuit of curing a pestilence that he
could not get the foundation to
understand creating lifeless zombies
whenever he attempted to treat a patient
where would this inscrucible doctor
disappear to if he only could what would
his Hideaway be the simulation rendered
a sterile laboratory environment no real
surprise given his proclivity for
medical science there were stainless
steel tables and instruments the plague
doctor stood in the fully outfitted lab
going about his work as he always did
with no one to interrupt or disturb him
on the desk in the corner set a pile of
medical texts a vase filled with
lavender flowers in fresh water and a
generous glass of Rich red wine there
was everything here that he could
possibly need what about a pocket
dimension for an entity that already had
everything it could possibly want
something so content so happy with its
everyday life that it had no need or
desire to escape
scp-999 lived as a pampered pet a sort
of foundation mascot with its every wish
for tasty treats or playtime met still
they inputted the tickle Monster's
information into the simulation to see
what it might come up with what it
rendered looked like something out of
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory it
was a wide open field beneath a bright
blue sky filled with sunlight and fluffy
white clouds the landscape however was
not The Greenery in nature one might
expect to see but instead was made up
entirely of candy and other sweets
Boulders made of toffee a lake of melted
chocolate lollipop trees and cotton
candy bushes as far as the eye could see
nestled within the candy landscape was
an elaborate playground Marvin amusement
park than the usual row of swings and a
plastic slide there was a miniature
Ferris wheel a ball pit and an obstacle
course that scp-999 could bounce around
and navigate every simple childlike Joy
was present in this place pure sweetness
happiness and light for a creature as
good as scp-999 they would expect
nothing less next up was The Dudley
statue that moved only when out of sight
SCP-173 it took the researchers a moment
to understand what they were seeing when
they took a look at its Dimension at
first they thought that perhaps the
simulation had somehow crashed after all
they were looking at a pitch black
screen then they realized they were
seeing what its Dimension would look
like after all the perfect place for
SCP-173 to retreat to would be somewhere
cloaked in absolute Darkness where no
one could keep an eye on the Statue and
stop it from moving as it pleased here
it would be free to hunt and take lives
as much as it wanted keeping
unsuspecting humans in suspense as they
waited for the sound of grinding stone
to betray that the end was near the
researchers all shuddered and glanced
over their shoulders just in case since
they were already feeling unsettled they
decided to take it one step further and
see what scp-682 might create for itself
what could be home for the creature that
hates everything they were horrified to
see oblique Stony landscape where the
massive reptile was devouring everything
in sight humans plants animals none were
safe from being snapped up in its deadly
Jaws that wasn't the worst of it though
when it had finished consuming
everything
scp-682 opened its mouth and coughed all
of its victims back up miraculously
resurrected and unharmed then it began
to do it all over again ripping tearing
and clawing at all the living things
around it in an cycle of Despair one
researcher began to feel sick and had to
flee the room the rest pressed on if a
bit paler than they had been moments
before since the Vibes in the room were
already as bad as they could possibly
get one researcher suggested they keep
the momentum going and try out another
highly hostile anomaly the possessive
mask itself
scp-035 what sort of cursed reality
could the simulation come up with for
the malicious mask a being that though
it could not move on its own seemed to
radiate an almost Unstoppable evil the
monitor showed a rendering of an
ornately decorated castle with a
medieval European sensibility gold decor
and Rich red velvet curtains dots of
black and red like blood and black goo
on everything on the walls elaborate
tapestries were hung depicting the
traditional comedy and tragedy masks
that scp-035 resembled there was a stain
glass window toward the back of the room
depicting
scp-035 with a full human body sitting
Atop A Golden Throne a crown on its head
in the very center of the room there was
scp-035 in a position matching the
stained glass window at its feet dozens
of people dressed in rags were kneeling
in supplication to their ruler the mask
was smiling of course that awful thing
would want to make itself the king of
its own private Castle forcing others to
serve its every whim time to shift gears
to something completely different
scp-2662 also known as Cthulhu despite
the creature's intimidating appearance
he was overall a relatively polite being
what would his chosen Sanctuary look
like
scp-2662's simulated pocket Dimension
was a far cry from the luxury of
scp-035s there were no riches here no
opulent displays of wealth and power it
was was the opposite the room depicted
resembled a standard studio apartment
with a bed a couch a television and a
kitchenette every up-to-date game
console and some that didn't exist yet
could be seen throughout the room and
posters for various video games and
action and Sci-Fi movies Adorn the walls
there were Stacks and stacks of games
ready to be played as well as an extra
large beanbag chair positioned directly
in front of the TV screen their
scp-2662 sat gaming happily the room had
no windows and no visible door either no
way for strangers to intrude on his
peaceful private Leisure Time up next on
the list was scp-953 the polymorphic
humanoid but when the simulation
rendered her pocket Dimension she was
nowhere to be seen there was a beautiful
landscape like something out of a
painting of what appeared to be an
idyllic location in rural Korea there
was vibrant green grass a light blue sky
dotted with delicate wisps of clouds and
a clear trickling stream there was a man
Lying by the stream basking in the
sunlight though he didn't look like any
anomaly the research team recognized
they were checking him for The Telltale
fox ears or tail that indicated a
shape-shifted scp-953 when suddenly a
figure emerged from the water a woman
with long dark hair wearing a white
dress and with those oh so familiar ears
poking out from her scalp she stretched
her sharp claws wide and snapped her
fingers suddenly the landscape changed
the sky went dark the clouds replaced
with Fox eyes glaring down from the
heavens the stream flowed red with blood
and the grass became a carpet of gnarled
orange fur the man scrambled to his feet
in a desperate bid for escape but
scp-953 jumped on him before he could so
much take a step away from her and began
to torture him gleefully the screen went
red as if with blood the researchers
definitely needed a palette cleanser
after that nightmarish Vision so they
selected a much more wholesome entity
from the list for the next round
scp-2295 the patchwork bear that so
deeply wanted to heal the world and help
the sick and hurting its simulated
Dimension resembled an ordinary doctor's
office waiting room with chairs a check
and desk and some toys and books for
board patients of all ages there was one
difference however everything in the
room was made from scrap Fabric and yarn
materials the bear could use to patch a
potentially infinite number of troubles
this was a place where the bear could
bring anyone in need of its help and
treat them to the best of its ability
but what about an anomaly that was not
sentient or at the very least one whose
sentience was very much Up For Debate
the team selected scp-914 for the next
simulation inputting the details of 914
or the Clockworks resulted in an image
of a small Factory with large metal
doors inside all manner of
unidentifiable Machinery worked in
tandem to rearrange and reconfigure
various items there were different
conveyor belts each marked according to
one of the Clockwork settings coarse
rough one-to-one fine and very fine
perhaps one researcher posited this
pocket Dimension was not theoretical at
all maybe this was where items went when
they disappeared into the machine's
intake Booth then again who could be
certain how exactly an item like scp-914
really worked next was
scp-073 or Kane in his Dimension the
world of Zone making he strolled through
a dense forest the vegetation thriving
all around him where it would have
ordinarily withered and died he plucked
an apple off a tree and took a bite
scp-529 Josie the half cat run through a
playroom that could only be described as
cat Heaven scratching posts Fish and
Chicken Treats balls of yarn everything
a feline friend could ever desire one
researcher wiped a tear from her eye and
when her colleagues questioned it she
just replied I really like cats okay in
a subject change another researcher
suggested trying a sort of before and
after experiment with the simulation
they would see what sort of pocket
Dimension might be generated by an
anomaly before a traumatic event and
what it might create after they settled
on scp-066 Eric's toy first they built
the simulation around
scp-066 as it first behaved when it
arrived at the SCP Foundation the result
produced was a world made of colorful
yarn filled with living yarn creatures
roaming around the landscape as Eric's
toy rolled among them cheerfully then
they inputted the details of the
incident that shifted the entity's
behavior when a d-class attempted to cut
off a piece of its yarn body for study
the resulting pocket Dimension was made
not of yarn but of fleshy tendrils
dripping with red that curled in arrived
like tentacles grasping and squeezing
aggressively at anything that intruded
on the space a striking visual
representation of the change in the
anomaly's mental and emotional state
next was
scp-1867 Lord Blackwood Lord blackwood's
pocket out of reality was the interior
of a grand hunting lodge with a roaring
fire in the fireplace and an impressive
if a bit Macabre bare-skinned rug
stretched across the floor Lord
Blackwood stood in all of his brightly
colored sea slug Glory at a bar in the
corner of the room next to a glass of
whiskey and a hand-carved wooden pipe
All Along The Wall were various trophies
Taxidermy of a variety of wild beasts
that the slug had hunted over the years
as well as artifacts picked up along its
travels fossils rare books paintings and
primitive weapons there were also grainy
old photographs of Lord Blackwood with
many of his associates from over the
years other famed Hunter and gentlemen
explorers he had embarked on his
Expeditions alongside
scp-4910 the grinner would dwell in a
volcanic landscape where Rock and lava
were replaced with fleshy pink gums and
teeth jutted out of every available
surface gnarly
scp-076 Abel would use his pocket
Dimension as a battle arena a grand
Coliseum of sorts filled with every
weapon imaginable where he could trap
his strongest would-be opponents and
force them into a fight to the death
scp-527 Mr fish's simulated Pocket World
resembled the city of Boston with one
notable difference every depiction of a
human being from statues to billboard
advertisements to magazine covers showed
them with fish heads atop their human
bodies there was not a human head to be
seen except at what would have
ordinarily been the seafood market there
you could find chests of ice-held fresh
human heads that were ready to be sold
though the side of the the human heads
was a bit disconcerting the research
team understood the significance of this
place it made sense that Mr Fish would
want to retreat to a world that matched
his lived experience where everyone else
looked like him there was even a hat
shop stocked with tiny little formal
hats like his very own top hat if
scp-2800 cactus man had a place between
realities that belonged exclusively to
him it would be an underground superhero
Hideout the room depicted on the monitor
resembled the bat cave but with all the
bat themed Decor replaced with
cactus-themed items instead there are
also several large seguro cacti planted
in pots throughout the space as well as
several Cactus Man costumes and glass
cases ready to be worn
scp-294 the coffee machine would have a
secret world filled with every liquid
substance known to man and several still
undiscovered floating through the air
but somehow never mixing together any
beverage anyone could ever ask for would
be there just waiting for the right
order to come in
scp-352 Baba Yaga was next it was a
large Forest seemingly ordinary at first
glance but within its depths lurked
every fear a person could ever have
depending on what unsuspecting victim
she was able to pull into the darkness
there could be a high up Cliffside
waiting for someone afraid of heights a
giant spider awaiting an arachnophobe or
thick Inky Blackness waiting for someone
Afraid of the Dark all around the forest
floor her hair curled waiting to ensnare
her prey
scp-662 more specifically
scp-662-1 Mr Deeds quite possibly
already occupied a pocket Dimension when
his Bell was not in use though they had
no way to know for certain the
simulation predicted that his break room
of sorts might look like this a blue
room with two shelves filled with
cleaning tools a brown couch and a
little bed in the corner where the
Butler could sleep during his time off
scp-169 Leviathan would disappear into
an aquatic pocket Dimension a place
large enough for it to swim comfortably
possibly forever in the peaceful
infinite ocean then the research staff
decided to input
scp-096 and see what the Shy Guy's
pocket Dimension might look like unlike
the old man this anomaly was not
aggressive all the time and it seemed to
take no pleasure in hunting instead it
acted in a kind of Twisted self-defense
attacking anything that saw its face and
set it off on a spree of violence that
ended in death
scp-096's potential pocket Dimension was
a dark dismal Labyrinth like something
out of the Greek myth of the Minotaur
Stone corridors Twisted this way in that
leading any potential Intruders down
dead ends and away from the center where
scp-096 hid from sight in the center
there was light and life try freeze
grass a small pond and a nest filled
with blind birds chirping and singing to
scp-096 as it sat in complete obscurity
away from prying eyes the man's bedroom
hadn't been silent for over 100 years
now the carpet had been worn down a
thick layer of dust had gathered on
every surface and the same trapped air
had stagnated for so long that had
become unbearable for anyone entering
the room but no one was allowed to enter
the room nobody could open that door
ever again or it could Mark the
beginning of not just an apocalypse but
a breakdown in the nature of reality
itself figures shuffled around the room
sometimes dozens sometimes as few as
three all rotting but never dying
researchers peered through the window in
abject Terror day after day as the laws
of physics broke down before their very
eyes all of them except except one a
lone scientist with a plan to get inside
that room a plan that the foundation
would shoot him dead for a plan that he
was seconds away from enacting as the
improvised explosive device in this
Satchel clunked heavily against his
thigh in many ways we are just as
trapped as scp-001 if not more so we are
trapped in our own three-dimensional
world take a stick figure drawn on a
piece of paper that stick figure knows
up and down left and right that is their
world you draw a box around them and
they are trapped unable to Simply step
forward out of the page and walk around
it for us looking down at the stick
figure we might laugh at their
foolishness trapped inside a child's
drawing of a house it begs the question
is there a creature looking down at us
and laughing we may be able to move up
and down left and right forward and
backward outsmarting the simple stick
figure but in time we are just as k
living our entire lives on this
razor-thin piece of paper called the
present the future is always just Out Of
Reach the past always repelling us we
have no choice but to exist in the now
slowly creeping through history without
any agency of our own cursed to be born
Live and Die in that order you can never
be a child again never see your mother's
face for the first time beaming down at
you you cannot skip ahead to your dying
minutes knowing what it is you will have
to face up to in your life maybe the
idea of facing up to things at all will
fade with the freedom of exploring what
once was and what will be as if it were
no more difficult than taking a step out
of a 2d box the bell rang cutting
Professor Davies off he hadn't meant to
go into such an existential tangent
especially for his first year students
most of them look like they were in a
daze not really listening to anything he
had been saying quantum mechanics sure
was was a complex topic to cover in just
one semester at University he'd spent
his entire career trying to wrap his
head around it and still spend most of
his days with the same bored and
Confused glaze over his eyes as the
teenagers who made their way to the back
of the hall but one figure standing just
beyond the doorway peering down at him
caught the professor's eye little did he
know how drastically his career was
about to change in just a few minutes a
preeminent physicist at just 28 years
old Professor Davies had already
achieved the status that many academics
will not see within their lifetimes
whenever anyone asked him about it he
always made the joke that he was
cheating he didn't believe in the
concept of a linear lifetime in the
first place still too young to be taken
seriously by many of his peers he had
flown under the academic radar for much
of his career so far perhaps it was as
simple as that or perhaps certain
undercover agents had a hand in
suppressing news of his blossoming
career in Quantum research his hands
trembled as he approached the reinforced
glass he gripped the bag tightly trying
his best not to let his fear show if any
of them saw what he was about to do they
even suspected something he would have a
dozen bullets flying through the back of
his skull before he'd even have a chance
to put his hands up shifting his weight
from foot to foot he waited for the
airlock to be open for him a siren
blared red lights flashed and the first
glass doors slid open stepping inside he
waited for the atmosphere in the chamber
to adjust both doors were closed in
front of and behind him if they wanted
to kill him now would be the time he
closed his eyes and waited with baited
breath the bomb weighing heavily on his
shoulder but they would not kill him he
knew that now what he was about to do
was inevitable it took several months
for Professor Davies to be granted the
full security clearance he needed they
kept referring to his project as a
k-class anomaly whatever that meant in
order to get him up to speed with the
nature of what he was going to be
working on the foundation assigned him
to various other scps first
scp-5027 2821 1887 any instance that had
stumbling to Quantum Mechanics or
complex theoretical physics they
wouldn't even tell him which SCP he was
being trained up to work on until one
morning when a team of Agents was
waiting for him at the door to his
quarters he wasn't allowed to bring a
bag or any personal possessions standard
issue clothing a toothbrush and
everything else he needed would all be
provided for him it was only then that
they told him which SCP he was being
assigned to
scp-001 he was blindfolded for the
entirety of the journey Carr then plane
than another car it was a full 10 hours
before his blindfold was removed and his
new project was revealed to him
professor Davies found himself in
sight01 the place where all all of this
started all the scps all the research
the secrecy the assassinations the
deaths of countless innocent people and
an equal number of guilty parties it all
started right here
site-01 the site itself resembled a
large sarcophagus similar to the one
found covering the Chernobyl nuclear
power plant where do you think the
Soviets got the blueprints from
everything in the room is arranged in a
circle around the center research desks
maintenance equipment raw materials
including a stockpile of wooden planks
and reinforced Metal Sheets monitoring
equipment security cameras and of course
some of the most advanced automatic
weapon systems in the world all pointed
at a great glass box in the middle of
the hangar measuring 30 meters in each
Direction the glass was 50 centimeters
thick even all those High Caliber
weapons would have had a hard time
creating a chip in that but it wasn't
the glass box itself that was so
interesting it was what was trapped
inside of it a house inside a perfectly
round glass bowl with no entrances or
exits complete with a front lawn
sidewalk porch and even a tree in the
backyard a regular American house
trapped in a box like some kind of
science experiment there was some kind
of transparent airlock system at the
entrance on the other side was just a
normal walk up the garden path to the
edge of the second glass bubble
enclosing the house but on closer
inspection Professor Davies realized
that this wasn't your typical American
house at all the Street Lamp wasn't
electric it was made of iron with little
glass paint Windows an oil lamp in fact
the house did look odd to him there was
no electric doorbell but instead an
actual physical Bell System the whole
house looked out of place not just
because it was in a box in the central
Hangar of a 42 000 ton sarcophagus but
because it was from another era entirely
you see site-01 was constructed around
the house the glass box and bubble
sarcophagus all of it was built around
the already existing building beneath
the foundations a hundred meters beneath
the surface is an immense metal plate
that forms a perfect seal with the
defenses up top the only way in and out
of sight01 is through an immense
reinforced door but even all those
defenses will prove utterly futile if
anyone ever opens the thin wooden door
to the bedroom on the top floor of the
house that is the home and the prison in
which scp-001 is trapped it is the job
of the foundation to make sure that it
remains trapped there indefinitely what
is
scp-001 as Professor Davies made his way
through the airlock for the very first
time and entered the site under the
supervision of four of the highest
ranking SCP staff alive today he laid
eyes on the entity itself for the first
time standing on a scissor lift parked
outside the front of the house just
inches away from the glass bubble it was
lifted high enough to look through the
window into what looked like a young
boy's bedroom on the top floor layers of
dust coated the surfaces black and white
photos sat in frames antique children's
toys sat all around the walls but Davies
didn't notice any of them he was too
busy watching the men walking in all
directions
unhurried but with purpose well over a
dozen men walked in all directions
across the carpeted floor they were all
identical around six feet with heavy
rotting skin that seemed to hang off
their limbs like it would a carcass left
in the sun human cadavers Milling about
in a young boy's bedroom Davies was so
taken aback by their appearance and
behavior that it took him a long time to
notice something truly strange the
reason he was brought here in the first
place they were walking through the bed
in the middle of the room not just over
it or around it but straight through it
as if it wasn't there but wait something
else was wrong too there weren't 12 of
them in the room it was closer to 20 had
he miscounted a moment ago then he saw
it take place one of the cadavers
reached the edge of the room and paused
as if in thought at that moment it split
not in half but rather two versions of
itself emerge from where one had been
standing both walking in different
directions a thrill of excitement ran
through Professor Davey's body the
uncertainty principle it was there in
action in front of him he was looking at
Schrodinger's cat inside the box and
seeing both its corpse and its living
self where uncertainty exists this
entity was somehow embodying both
possibilities in real time he watched
the two selves walk around the room
following different paths for several
minutes until eventually they converged
again back into one being he turned to
the researcher accompanying him lit up
with excitement and asked what they were
doing here the researcher's face was
Grim when he replied their pacing
waiting the airlock door hissed open he
felt the stale 1800s air hitting his
face perfectly maintained at 20 degrees
in front of him was the Garden Path
leading up to his goal that glass bubble
ripping the Satchel he set off up the
path slow enough not to attract any
unwarranted attention over the next few
days Professor Davies learned everything
that the foundation had on scp-001 it
had been a human once a radical
physicist born in the late 19th century
intent on kick-starting the next Century
with a nuclear Renaissance the young man
had created a working model for stable
nuclear fusion the potential
ramifications were enormous free clean
electricity on a mass scale with no
harmful byproducts his research was
almost complete when a covert private
military group poisoned him with his own
radioactive nuclear agent the young man
made it back to his house where he died
in his sleep that night powerful
military personnel and prominent
scientists who had been working
alongside the young man knew immediately
what had happened bursting into his home
they were about to walk through his
bedroom door and save him when they saw
the shadow of two feet standing by the
door then another pair the young
scientist had died but he also hadn't
much like Schrodinger cat the man was
suspended in a dual state of death and
not death this shocking Discovery led
the group of people present to form a
rudimentary Foundation established to
secure and contain their once friend
within his room never to be discovered
by The Wider world through close
observations since this time it has been
established that scp-001 exists
independently of linear time in a kind
of superposition relative to the world
around it it is capable of occupying any
space that will or has been empty at any
point in time say you have two chairs in
a room one chair has always been there
the other was added to the room just
five minutes before the SCP is unable to
walk through the chair that was always
there since it has always existed but
the chair that was added can be passed
through with no problem because there
was a point in time when that chair had
not been there but it also works in the
future if a third chair was present
which had always been there but was
removed five minutes after the
experiment SCP
001 could pass through that chair also
the foundation theorizes and hopes that
the start of this clock that scp-001
operates on was the point at which the
young scientist died and did not die
that is why it is incapable of escaping
its bedroom and that is why it is of
vital importance that the bedroom door
remains closed forever ongoing
maintenance work and preservation
techniques are being employed to keep
the house in as stable a state as
possible should anything happen to
damage the Integrity of the structure
the quantum chaos contained in that
space could lead to a total breakdown of
the laws of physics destroying not just
the world but the fundamentals of
mathematics as we know them the bomb
bumped against Professor Davey's thighs
he walked up to the house an old man
whose life had been devoted to denying
the world its future a reality where
what is and what could be are just as
real as one another a world where the
pain of living in the now Fades when you
can travel to any moment in your life
and relive its Joy when you aren't
trapped by the aging process infinite
renewable energy to solve The World's
problems a chance to see your deceased
loved ones again a way to look at the
universe Through The Eyes Of God the
head of 001 containment he had spent his
entire career overriding all of the
safeguards tweaking containment rules
just enough each year also he could walk
across this grass with a satchel on his
shoulder and an explosive more important
than the atomic bomb at his hip he
approached the glass of the inner sphere
if he had done the math right this
should do just enough damage to create a
hole in the containment structure the
pressure change wouldn't be too great
inside but it should be just enough to
blow say a bedroom door wide open stop
right up folks we've got all kinds of
refreshing and tasty treats here for you
today popcorn peanuts cotton candy and
even fried dough yes sir here at SCP
explained we're offering the top of the
line anomalous delectable foodstuffs for
all your circus themed fun time
occasions and that's because today yes
today on this YouTube platform our
Infamous acronym doesn't stand for
secure contain protect it stands for
sweet confectionary products let me tell
you dear viewer the SCP we're looking at
today just might be the most decadent
durable and dangerous dessert that's
ever desired to be devoured we're
talking about
scp-3077 or as they are better known the
sugar Golems these little fellas are
safe class and also totally harmless so
long as you take the proper precautions
what's the matter don't you believe me
don't you think it's nice of us to cover
a safe SCP now and again and hey now why
all this dull talk about rules and
regulations in the first place you don't
go out to the carnival to not take wild
and exciting risks every spinny twirly
and whirly ride on the fairgrounds comes
with a statistically higher chance of a
tragic mishap the following you and any
other Thrill Seekers around you but we
all take that chance anyway for the
extraordinary Rush of the experience and
such is the wacky and wonderful ways of
our adorable and questionably edible
Chums the sugar Golems don't you just
love them folks and they are safe for
sore eyes and are paying for sweet teeth
well we're only just getting started The
Best Is Yet To Come ladies and not
ladies so pull up a channel and be sure
to watch what we've got in store you can
make like a piece of old candy and stick
around now that's a knee slapper Raymond
back relax and make sure to enjoy the
show you should also subscribe to SCP
explained if you'd like to continue to
be entertained hey that rhyme what do
you know I'm about and I didn't even
know it I'll draw well scp-3077 refers
to the anomalous substance contained in
site 81. the semi-humanoid instances
which are nicknamed sugar Golems are
themselves inanimate and independent
byproduct that naturally spawns from
scp-3077 when it is allowed to exist
outside of containment procedures the
most important of these containment
procedures being that scp-3077 must
remain at a constant temperature of well
below its freezing point and only be
stored in containers fall to capacity
less its aforementioned byproducts
attempt to breach containment the total
volume of scp-3077 within the cryogenic
containment unit equals almost
2200 liters and it is believed to be the
only known quantity of the anomalous
substance in existence for the sake of
clarity in distinguishing between
scp-3077 and it's by AI products will be
referring to the main object contained
by the foundation as scp-3077 while the
gooey little guys who we know to
spontaneously split off from the source
of scp-3077 will be regarded as
scp-3077-1 as mentioned before
scp-3077-1 instances have been
affectionately dubbed these sugar Golems
every instance of scp-3077-1 resembles
an approximately one meter tall gaunt
humanoid composed of a pure sugar
derived substance commonly known as
prickle and that's Molasses for all
y'all yeah Cowboys over there in the US
of a if you've ever played the classic
board game Candyland you'll have some
idea of what an individual instance of
scp-3077 looks like from the Beloved and
often remembered character of Gloppy who
lives in the Molasses swamp section of
the board and is also fittingly made out
of molasses himself yes indeed Gloppy is
truly a delight for a weary cam
underline player to meet what did you
say are you folks too young to know
about Candyland well that factoid
certainly makes this narrator feel
pretty old then again I am taking on the
mannerisms and attire of an
old-fashioned Carnival marker so I
suppose a bit of Novel Antiquity comes
with the territory regardless the Golems
are each composed of roughly seven
liters of sweet syrupy goodness and very
much like everyone's favorite character
Gloppy they all like to find lower
bodies and can all emote through crude
yet oddly endearing vocalizations in the
place of intelligible speech while their
facial features are simplistic and
misshapen the Contours of concave eyes
and gaping mouth are usually present the
exact number of these eyes and mouths is
subject to variation much like the color
of the board spaces in a wonderful
wholesome family game of Candyland while
hscp 3077-1 instance is around the same
size the body proportions and overall
shape of each instance are rather fluid
pan fully intended
oversized arms or bulbous heads While
others might be conjoined to an adjacent
sugar Golem as if to show that the two
are inseparable as a pair of best
buddies or as some others might put it a
couple of BFFs best friends for fancy
frolicking they really are quite
friendly looking aren't they and aren't
they they sure are but the only thing
that these sugary sweet SCP instances
want is to be in the company of human
beings just like you yes you who else
would I be talking to it's a hard life
for this one down Connie let me tell you
these little sugar Golems love what they
do and do what they love but that
doesn't mean that it's time for fun and
games even though
scp-3077-1 instances want to hang around
human beings they don't tend to stop at
hey and hello or whatever those
appropriate greetings sound like when
they are being gurgled by a diminutive
molten sugar monster things can get out
of hand real fast just like an orange
cream popsicle melting in the sound of a
late summer's day now listen up it's
important that you pay attention to what
I say next I'm about to book learn you
about what to do with an instance of
scp-3077-1 enters your personal space
the results of prolonged contact with
this SCP can end badly if you're not
careful I'm not going to sugarcoat any
of the chewy details of your Grizzly
fate and I promise that it won't be a
cakewalk so don't be a nerd and listen
up yes that's right I called you a nerd
you know like nerds the candy how do you
folks seriously not know nerds they were
classic Halloween candy from the Wonka
company and they were very popular back
in the day oh was that you say how long
ago was it back in the day for me well
that's a bit of a rude question wouldn't
you say oh
won't you go ahead and knock it off with
the Wise Guy questions what are you a
pack of Smarties I said Smarties get it
just like that ah never mind let's just
move on to the explanation of how to
survive a close encounter with this SCP
that was the main reason you came all
this way to this here educational and
entertaining video presentation after
all to pick up where I left off
instances of scp-3077-1 have a tendency
to seek out nearby human life the reason
for doing so is surprisingly simple and
alarmingly well alarming these sticky
sacrine simulacra are solely set on
slithering into people's mouths for the
purposes of gaining total control of
their bodies Yes you heard that right
believe it or not the same anomalous
property which animates the sugar
Golem's trickle bodies is apparently
capable of overriding the human nervous
system from the inside and that's no
joke folks while these tasty treats
might sound sweet to eat you'll be a
puppet of meat from your head to your
feet if you don't complete the tasks I
entreat if an instance of scp-3077-1
attempts to enter your mouth you you
must remember first and foremost to keep
your trap shut blocking it with a mask
or a similar article of clothing if need
be next you must use your limbs and all
available implements to better the
attacking Golem away while you do your
best to keep a distance of at least Arms
Reach between yourself and the instance
it should come as a relief to our
rational people that scp-3077-1
instances are severely limited in their
physical capabilities and an adult human
of average fitness can easily hold one
off if they know what to expect the
tricky part comes from the amorphous
properties of the instances of viscous
critical bodies as well as their
anomalous ability to regenerate from any
physical trauma the only way to
permanently destroy an instance of
scp-3077-1 is to expose it to
temperatures above its melting point
which for you sticklers out there is
approximately 176 degrees Celsius the
most effective weapons against
scp-3077-1 in instances include
firebombs flamethrowers and your
run-of-the-mill convection ovens if it
is at all possible to contain the
instance within a sealed vessel such as
a large Tupperware or wooden barrel then
you ought to do whatever you can to
prevent the candy creeps from running
amok while ordinary below zero
temperatures are unable to destroy the
anomalous trickle of scp-3077 instances
of
scp-3077-1 can effectively be slowed
down or stopped completely if you put
them on Ice whether it's the hot foot or
the cold shoulder some form of extreme
temperature should always be weaponized
when defending oneself from an
scp-1377-1 instance any attempt to crush
or smash an scp-3077-1 instance will
only result in the bad Bonbon breaking
apart and reforming into several more
belligerent bite-sized blighters a human
Under Siege by the sugar Golems might
find themselves quickly outnumbered if
they foolishly attempt to use a melee
weapon against the anomaly days
basically it's like a more delicious
version of the popular arcade video game
asteroids no I guess that reference was
from before even my time at any rate
instances of scp-3077-1 are difficult to
destroy without access to heat or
freezing the tendency of the Molasses
Menace is to increase in number is made
even worse because of the fact that any
amount of scp-1377 outside of
containment can generate a nearly
infinite number of
scp-3077-1 while even an army of
scp-3077-1 instances is far weaker than
an equivalent pack of hunting animals
the ability to continuously multiply and
Physiology that doesn't experience the
consequences of fatigue means that given
enough time these sugar Golems can
Outlast any amount of human resistance
until they roll over their preferred
prey like a slow insurmountable syrupy
tsunami of surrender seriously scary
stuff some would say but what happens
next is the real kicker folks mine is
baliho's summer Spiel if an instance of
scp-1377-1 manages to Against All Odds
clamor its way into a human Chatterbox
and hijack the poor Sap's nervous system
the victim is immediately classified as
scp-3077-2
scp-3077-2 instances are easily
distinguished from unaffected humans on
site alone dark tendrils of scp-1377 can
be seen visibly moving beneath the skin
and often emerge from the mouth to
crisscross the instance's face like
makeup the world's most disturbing
circus clown that's not all after the
tragic trickly transformation takes
place the movements exhibited by the
instance of
scp-3077-2 will become crooked and Jerky
like a marionette puppeteered by a
frustrated chimpanzee during this time
the instance remains fully conscious
retaining whatever cognitive faculties
it has possessed previous to its
classification but it is unable to
attempt speech or exert autonomy over
its own actions this fun fact was
discovered by studying the EEG
recordings of several
scp-3077-2 instances and is brought to
you by the United Guild of the
existentially terrified if an instance
scp-3077-2 happens to wander its way
into the vicinity of any humans that
haven't succumbed to the process of
consuming
scp-3077-1 it will proceed to put on a
jaunty performance for its Newfound
audience this peculiar display involves
clumsy efforts at dance choreography and
the throaty singing of unsettling
Eternal Melodies that would make your
annoying cousins road trip songs sound
like they're in tune these awkward
performances continue until the audience
departs from the view of
scp-1377-2 instance or the instance
expires this confirms that the point of
the gesture is to entertain as without
an audience the
scp-3077-2 instance is not compelled to
make any noises of its own accord and in
general doesn't do anything other than
move around aimlessly in the event that
any number of
scp-3077-1 instances escapes from
containment and causes the creation of
scp-3077-2 members of the mobile task
force are instructed to never stray from
the line of sight of a currently
performing
scp-3077-2 instance and to approach it
steadily before restraining the instance
while causing minimal harm to the body
scp-3077-2 instances can be useful for
running further tests on the anomalous
properties of scp-3077 and there are
simple procedures that allow an instance
to be kept alive indefinitely in
containment any damage sustained doesn't
capture can severely hamper the
efficiency of these life-sustaining
procedures the worst case scenario is
that an
scp-3077-2 instance expires before being
securely contained as this will cause
the scp-3077-1 instance to emerge from
its host and resume its Relentless
attack on all nearby humans it is far
easier to Simply deal with
scp-3077-2 instances accordingly and
this is because
scp-3077-2 only ever attempts to
continue the performance and possesses
neither the intention nor the capacity
for retaliation if it is deemed
necessary for the effectiveness of a
recapture effort it can be permissible
for the model task force to allow
instances of scp-3077-1 outside of
containing to find purchase within
scp-3077-2 to increase the ease of
containment and lessen the risk of
foundation Personnel being affected the
performances of
scp-3077-2 instances are rarely
physically intensive enough to make
capture too difficult but it can be said
that the Whimsical antics of these
affected humans are anything but
predictable during some rare and special
performances and if the scp-3077-1
instance in control of
scp-3077-2 instance is feeling
especially daring it may try to show off
an array of woefully inadequate
acrobatic skills front flips that are
more like belly flops backflips that
could be mistaken for pret Falls and the
sort of type Road Pen trapezags that are
better left to the imagination in lieu
of Playa incidents the foundation
strongly advises that if for any reason
an instance of
scp-3077-2 must exist in containment it
must always be prevented from being at
an altitude of more than six feet from
the surface of the floor especially if
any humans it would perceive as an
audience are located directly beneath
where its performance would take place
regarding the creation of other
instances of
scp-3077-2 requests from any level of
foundation Personnel at site 81 or
elsewhere must be granted permission to
proceed by scp-3077's head researcher
because of the horrific implications of
what happens to the stellawair human
mind while the body is affected by
scp-3077-1 this process is only to be
approved for use on d-class Personnel
that's right and even then in the event
that all the regular all of the
paperwork goes through it is not
acceptable to create an instance of
scp-3077-2 merely for the purpose of
providing live entertainment to fellow
researchers after all not a single one
of us should be quick to forget the
grotesque and highly regrettable
spectacle that was Dr dietz's deplorable
d-class dancers every researcher
involved with that ethical nightmare was
reprimanded severely and the colorful
novelty costumes and jangling bells that
all former d-class Personnel were made
to wear after being reclassified to
scp-3077-2 have been permanently
confiscated let the cotton candy machine
and peanut dispenser located just
outside the containment unit of scp-3077
serve as a stand reminder that there's a
time and place for Monkey Shines and
and sometimes yes even now and then a
highly secure Foundation facility is
neither the right place nor the right
time in case you haven't picked up on it
there are very few practical
applications of scp-3077 due to the fact
that its status as a food dish is
negated by the consequences of
consumption the main reason for tests to
be administered on
scp-1377-2 instances is to discover if
there is a safe method of extracting an
scp-3077-1 instance from the body of its
host without causing the exploration of
the original human unfortunately due to
a persistent lack of success the
experiments have been discontinued
indefinitely but that just won't do how
else are we supposed to know if these
things actually taste as good as they
look I won't rest until everyone is able
to harmlessly ingest a sugar Golem of
their very own I might be old-fashioned
but to me the safe object class isn't
just a designation it's an invitation
again I ought to be completely okay
doing whatever I like around a saved
object because it's safe that word
should actually mean something ding ding
darn it and I don't mean that in the
sense that the SCP Foundation uses it
meaning an anomaly that doesn't present
an active threat to containment efforts
and more importantly there aren't that
many anomalies that are also delicious
candy and I want to eat this one sorry
sorry sorry I lost my cool a bit there I
just have a sweet tooth and my brain is
constantly drifting back to my nostalgic
childhood memories of playing Candyland
with my family that was before they all
decided that they wanted nothing to do
with me because I became so obsessed
with dressing up like a carnival marker
that I drove away everyone who's ever
cared about me other than that my job
here at the foundation explaining
confectionaries CPS is the only thing I
have left in my sad sad life some days I
feel less like Gloppy and more like a
real lord licorice in Hard Times Like
These a fellow could really use some
entertainment to cheer himself up wait
just a flea jumping moment what was that
what a big idea how do these Escape
instances of
scp-1377-2 get in here they're all
supposed to be in safe containment a few
floors down did somebody else from the
research team let them in here because
they knew I was in costume standing in
front of a pretend Fairground set that's
in pretty poor taste don't you think pun
very much intended I should probably
report it to the head researcher that
would be the ethical reasonable thing to
do then again look at them go those are
sure some hilarious dances I'm
definitely seeing a Snappy attempt at
doing the Charleston uh classic and is
that one doing the wormer is it just
kind of flopping on the floor I think
one of these instances knows about that
fortnite stuff how the kids are into
these days but I'm not sure if the human
element or the Golem that decides what
dances it knows either way this was
exactly what I needed to feel so much
better for once it feels like I'm
actually at a carnival instead of just
pretending to be at one now this is the
greatest performance I've ever seen in
all my years which you can be sure that
there have been a lot of the diver
screams A Silent Scream as the giant
Squid's beak digs into his skin its many
grasping tentacles grabbing him and
holding him in place nearby his fellow
divers are driven half mad with Terror
as they see mysterious figures floating
towards them through the Merc and
strange Russian voices speaking in in
their heads nobody can help them they're
down too deep too consumed by the
darkness and the pressure of the sea
they're now at the mercy of whatever is
inside the submarine beginning in the
1940s with the dawn of nuclear weapons
the American government conducting the
world's first atomic weapons test and
the Soviet Union responding in kind with
nuclear testing of their own the two
Powers entered an arms race fueled by
rivalry and a thirst to prove their
strength on the world stage what
followed were Decades of Staggering
technological advancements as each
Nation tried to outdo and intimidate the
other the Soviet Union crossed into the
cold reaches of outer space deploying
the satellite Sputnik the United States
responded with the founding of NASA
tensions reached a fever pitch during
the Cuban Missile Crisis of 1962 as
United States citizens feared they were
teetering on the brink of nuclear war in
July of 1968 the Soviet Union the United
Kingdom and the United States came
together to sign the treaty on the
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons
agreeing to abandon their pursuit of
increasing nuclear power and turn their
focus to disarmament but several months
before the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as
scp-741
scp-741 is the underwater wreckage of a
Soviet submarine that sank in March of
1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999. the submarine a
version of the Charlie II class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the
U.S government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible Euclid or
ketterclass anomaly in the rack at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hull was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seemed to have left something
behind whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a manned Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described an incident report
1741-a divers a26 through a30 embarked
from the Icebreaker yamal into the
waters below with the intention of
studying the potential anomalous
activity surrounding the wreckage as the
group of divers approached the submarine
they could feel the shift in the water
around them the oppressive feeling of
abnormally increasing pressure bearing
down and threatening to crush them if
their specialized diving equipment were
to fail they knew that that would be it
and the command would have to come and
fish their corpses out of the water or
even worse they would vanish entirely
meeting the same mysterious fate as the
crew of that doomed submarine but they
couldn't fixate on that they had a job
to do at first glance the wreckage
appeared undisturbed unchanged since the
previous inspection still they needed to
take a closer look to be sure as the
team got closer to the vessel a30 was
startled by the site of movement from
within the wreckage spotting motion
through one of the holes in the
structure as something passed by he
pointed it out to his colleagues but
they dismissed it as likely a giant
isopod or spider crab which were
crawling all over the surrounding area
a30 laughed off his jumpiness agreed
that they were probably right and
continued the exploration as planned
control authorized the divers to proceed
to the next step and a29 activated sonar
and lights moving toward the starboard
side breach there a faint glowing caught
his eye the glow resembled that of
radioactive material but when the team
checked the radiation levels in the area
they remained stable whatever the source
of the glow was it wasn't radioactive at
this point his Neutron counter began to
register something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
this
can you hear me the voice was muffled
and though could be heard over their
communication channels it emanated from
somewhere in the wreckage deep deep
underwater as a29 watched a glowing
shape emerged from the darkness it was
only an outline the suggestion of a
silhouette but the shape was undeniably
familiar it looked like a person the
other divers quickly noted the operation
2 and began to panic some checked their
nitrogen levels believing it to be some
sort of nitrogen Narcosis While others
pointed out that they couldn't all be
suffering from nitrogen Narcosis at the
same time the unknown voice continued
speaking saying if me it is getting hard
to breathe the divers debated what to do
next question whether what they were
seeing was even real when all at once
the humanoid figure vanished from sight
the divers attempted to shake off the
startling encounter and they resumed
their duties the investigation
proceeding as normal after a few moments
of uneventful work another Interruption
presented itself in the form of a five
meter long squid swimming around the
wreckage its presence startled the
divers at first particularly those
closest to the animal but the others
encouraged them to ignore it citing the
fact that there are no records of these
squid attacking humans so they did
continuing their work as the squid
circled them with apparent curiosity a27
spotted an unusual shell below the
wreckage notably large and difficult to
identify and control requested that they
bring it up to the surface for further
inspection by a marine biologist the
diver began attaching Hall cables to the
Shell as the squid crept closer and
closer all of a sudden a26 screamed and
there was a sudden Bloom of blood in the
water this squid despite it being
uncharacteristic behavior for its
species attacked the diver biting him
savagely prompted by cries for help from
the diving team control began to reel
a26 back towards the surface proceeding
slowly to give him decompression time
and the squid took advantage of the slow
Retreat it chased after the diver
grabbing hold of him and biting down
again tearing away at him as it gripped
him in its tentacles still control
continued reeling him in hoping to free
him from the Squid's grasp as they
yanked him to the surface the other
divers were ordered to get themselves
out of there as fast as possible in
order they gladly obeyed as they swam
back to the surface a30 saw something
else moving in the depths he couldn't
make out what it was but the sight of it
gave him a sick feeling of dread deep in
the pit of his stomach the four divers
were recovered alive along with the
shell examination of the shell indicated
that it resembled that of the extinct
orthoconic nautiloids but it was not
fossilized was taken for further study
given the possible implication of
extinct species anomalously manifesting
in the vicinity of scp-714 diver a26
lost a limb and was exposed to an
unknown Venom via bites from the
attacking squid his camera was destroyed
in the process as squid are not known to
attack humans unprovoked this Behavior
has been attributed to the influence of
scp-741 though the exact link between
the two is yet to be determined an
anomalous pressure gradient surrounds
the wreck with a radius of approximately
250 meters starting around the center of
the submarine the pressure in this area
is much greater than it should be given
the depth of the waters there this
unusually high pressure makes sonar
analysis extremely difficult as well as
threatening the safety of any divers in
the vicinity of the rack the few records
that the foundation has managed to
obtain from the Russian and U.S
governments indicate that the submarine
was being used to transport some sort of
secret cargo though the specifics of
this cargo are still unknown there is
reason to believe that it differed from
any type of nuclear or chemical Weaponry
on a date redacted from official files
the scps basisti was patrolling the area
around scp-741 when its sonar detected
some unknown entity approaching scp-741
from the south at a pace of 46 knots the
crew compared the acoustic signature of
the contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
basisti attempted to reach the contact
via sonobui drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an underseen missile launch
and vasisti responded with the utmost
urgency the ship broke away from its
original area and fired a type 53
torpedo at the underwater threat 15
seconds after the basisti launched its
torpedo missiles of an unidentified
configuration were seen breaking the the
water flying at a height of 1.8 meters
and a velocity of 0.92 Mach the missiles
did not emit any detectable radar nor
did they respond to any launch chaff or
flares from the viciste both of the
missiles were engaged by besiste's 3kn5
kinsal surface-to-air missiles and
cashdan point defense systems and were
destroyed at 1800 meters and 210 meters
from Impact respectively after the
missiles were neutralized the Hostile
vessel could be heard engaging in
evasive maneuvers at this point there
were four closely spaced explosions and
the sound of a submarine disintegrating
the identity of the attacker as well as
its intention toward scp-741 have not
yet been determined the incident
resulted in the foundation research team
suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net as well as additional Patrol
and defense assets placed in the area
additionally they advised an acquisition
of undersea retaliatory capability the
incident was classified incident 1741 C
the sonar recordings from the scps
basisti during incident
1741-c were taken for further analysis
by the research team the in-depth review
revealed anomalous acoustic signatures
that did not match up with any known
forms of propulsion including
magnetohydrodynamic drive currently the
nature of the unidentified attacker
remains a mystery and it has not been
attributed to any particular government
or organization following the incident
involving the scps basisti an American
intelligence agent reached out to the
foundation offering further insight into
the secretive government programs
looking into
scp-741 he agreed to sit for an
interview with a foundation researcher
assigned to the project on the condition
that his identity remained protected the
SCP researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
the foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the U.S
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too now the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff that redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crewmen were buried
Just Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't is something I can't
fully explain this particular statement
puzzled the foundation researcher
raising questions he hadn't anticipated
only uniforms did this mean that the sub
had been unmanned the informant replied
no no not unmanned there were no bodies
but personal effects were everywhere
along with uniforms there was some blood
human before you ask on one of the
Torpedoes in a bit of skin where
somebody probably crushed his hand load
in the thing just no bodies left when I
first looked into all this I had no clue
what the hell had gone on down there but
I started putting things together the
foundation agent began to speculate
based on the mounting evidence could it
have been a Soviet weapons program a
deadly biological agent of some kind no
no it wasn't that I thought maybe it
could have been so I dialed up some of
my contacts at vile preparent a spies
wind up owning each other favors after a
while and they denied it vehemently not
your usual cover-up baloney either they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted no
part of it sounded like he was gonna
puke when I mentioned redacted doctor do
you have any idea what it takes to make
a bioweapons researcher sick now that
wasn't what really bugged me though what
really kept me awake at night was the
KGB file that fell into our hands they
mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the U.S of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too loaning you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that scp-741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships as CPS basisti and
krasno yarsk has been selected for this
purpose if any unauthorized activity
occurs in the area surrounding scp-741
nuclear and conventional missiles may be
deployed any movement of scp-741 is
grounds for an immediate Nuclear Strike
whatever Secrets as CP 741 holds
whatever it was transporting that was
even more of an uncontrollable threat
than nuclear warfare they're better left
alone down there at the bottom of the
sea Nothing in life can prepare you for
the raw heat of a house on fire throwing
an arm up in front of his eyes and
clasping a handkerchief to his mouth
Robert chetford hacked up half of the
contents of his lungs glancing at the
material he saw that his phlegm was
black poisoned by the smoke a beam
collapsed in front of him sending a
fresh wave of burning air into his face
so hot that it felt like it was going to
Scorch his ears off he had to run he had
to get out of the house but he knew he
couldn't his mother was upstairs Robert
barreled his way through the Flames
shouldering open doors and stumbling
along long hallways the air was so thick
with smoke that he could barely breathe
so he collapsed to the floor and started
to crawl on his stomach he reached the
first step of the grand staircase and
started to heave himself up one at a
time feeling the heat of the house
threatening to engulf him more with
every inch he climbed but he hadn't made
it more than five steps before there was
an enormous creaking sound and the whole
staircase collapsed beneath him Sparks
rushed up into the air and swirled
around the room Flames licked at the
walls all around him as Robert looked
around at the collapsed staircase he
knew that it was hopeless with tears
streaming down his cheeks he pushed
himself forward and ran out of the house
the firemen swarmed past him filling the
building and shouting to one another but
Robert just stood there staring up at
the top floor window on the other side
of the glass surrounded by billowing
smoke he looked up at his mother sitting
as she always did on her rocking utterly
motionless as the house burned around
her in an undisclosed facility in the
United States of America you will find
what may well be the lowest security
containment cell in the entire SCP
Foundation there is no heavily armored
door no bulletproof glass no machine
guns about to drop down from the ceiling
at any point in fact there's very little
in the way of containment at all they
often leave the door to the cell wide
open there is a window but on the other
side of it isn't a crowd of researchers
security guards and agents ready to
spring into action at a moment's notice
it's just a normal double glazed window
that looks out across a Vista of fields
trees and a couple of power lines facing
the window is an old armchair in which
the concrete man sits
scp-014 he spends all of his day every
day staring out of the window this view
specifically was chosen because very
little changes in it night turns today
the trees change with the seasons and it
rains occasionally but there are no
roads no new buildings springing up
nothing to distinguish it from how it
looked in
1937 beside him is a small table home to
a record player in the corner of the
room there's an antique set of shelves
that house three dozen old records all
dated from the 1930s or earlier all day
every day the music plays out of the old
speaker every so often as researchers
walk up and down the corridor if they
hear that there isn't any music playing
they'll come into the room and change
the record over for a new one the newest
researchers check in with scp-014 to see
if he's okay he rarely responds and so
before long they stop asking you would
think therefore that the concrete man is
elderly approaching the Twilight years
of his life but the man who sits there
in his chair staring out of the window
and listening to music from almost 100
years ago appears to be just 30 years
old friends of Robert chetford reported
a noticeable change in his demeanor
following the fire and death of his
mother he had lost his father not long 4
to a workplace accident William chetford
had been a construction worker climbing
up the girders of New York's emerging
Skyline pouring concrete and piling
bricks he had been working on a new
building one that was said to be the
tallest in the world called the Empire
State Building day after day he would
climb the cranes Teeter precariously
over the dizzying drops any slight
mistake and he would plummet hundreds of
feet often to the busy streets below
sure enough one day William chetford's
worst fears came to life it was walking
on a gangplank that wobbled and bent
with every step he took on his shoulders
was a metal bar with a bucket of
concrete dangled precariously from each
tip he walked this route every day but
clearly that day proved too much for the
wood to take the board splintered and
split beneath him plunging him down and
down through the scaffolding William
desperately reached out an arm and
managed to grasp the edge of a girder he
hung there helplessly staring up at his
colleagues high above him he cried out
for help and upon seeing him they began
to scramble down level by level to try
and rescue him he just needed to hang on
for a moment longer and they would
rescue him but one of them knocked over
a bucket of concrete William chetford
could do nothing but watch as the heavy
sludge slowly tumbled towards his face
he tried to dodge it but it was no use
the company told Mrs chetford that this
had been William's Saving Grace that he
had been unconscious for the long fall
down to the streets below his fellow
workers knew that this wasn't the case
they heard his screams all the way down
Mrs chetford didn't believe any of it
they were lying all of them the company
his co-workers everybody she knew what
had really killed him it was the same
thing that was killing her slowly the
same thing that had been passed on to
their son concrete poisoning she'd
approached the Wall Street Journal New
York Times and any Outlet she could but
none of them were remotely into
interested in the story there were
chemicals in the concrete it wasn't safe
to use it never had been she'd been
working in nursing homes and seen the
effects of concrete on construction
workers they become paralyzed unable to
move spending so many years breathing
concrete air letting it absorb into
their skin their bodies had slowly
started to turn into it she knew it she
started to go crazy pinning up news
clippings medical journals photographs
Maps anything she could find all over
her walls her entire bedroom she had red
string hanging from the walls and
ceiling connecting to every surface
Robert watched helplessly from the
doorway unable to do anything as he saw
his mother steadily entering into
psychosis but the further her paranoia
went the less energy she seemed to have
for it weeks went by and her manic
fervor was replaced with lethargy she
got slower and slower in her movements
talked less and less at meal times and
began to sit down for extend ended
chunks of the day Robert assuming that
she was tired from grief did what he
could to help he carried an armchair up
to her room and placed it in the corner
by the window so that she could look out
over the world around her he thought she
was resting but it soon became apparent
that she wasn't really resting she was
withdrawing almost freezing over
desperate to try and get his mother to
re-engage with the world Robert sat down
with her to try and understand all of
her conspiracy theories around his
father's death she explained slowly and
calmly that the concrete being used in
New York was poisoned cursed she didn't
know where it had been dug up from how
it had been mixed or who was behind it
but she was getting close maybe it was
the US government maybe it was the same
witches maybe it was God himself but she
knew her husband and she knew he
wouldn't have fallen that day it walked
across that plank thousands of times
without incident there was no way he
would have made that mistake Robert
tried to connect the dogs of what she
was saying did she really think that it
was the concrete that had killed his
father she said that it was and that the
same concrete is now killing her she
showed him her hands turned them over
front and back under the light for him
to inspect they looked just like normal
hands elderly wrinkled with deep veins
popping out but normal she scratched at
them and tried to feign pain for the
effects of her fingers look she said
you'll see that powder coming off of
them that's concrete powder but Robert
didn't see any of it the concrete man
came to the foundation's attention a
couple decades ago construction workers
in New York in the late 1990s were hard
at work clearing out the foundations for
a new skyscraper the site was built on
top of what used to be a residential
block the one Intrepid Builder soon
discovered Something That Shook him to
his core there was an old seller beneath
where the building used to be the lock
on it was Heavy thick with rust and had
been open for close to 70 years he and
his team managed to pry it open put on
their flashlights and went inside what
they found was a basement apartment
still sitting there beneath the rubble
it was a relic of its time thick dust
covered every surface
ugly wallpapers surrounded them and
ancient appliances covered with rust sat
in the kitchen it was almost like
walking through a haunted house the
builders joked about ghosts stalking
these corridors as they made their way
through until they reached the bedroom
sliding the door open they faced a man
sitting there staring at them from an
old armchair the four Burly Builders
screamed like little girls for a split
second then burst out laughing when they
realized that the man wasn't real he
must have been a wax work or something
he was sitting so perfectly still and
hadn't reacted at all to their presence
they went over to inspect what he was
made out of they tapped on his forehead
lifted his arms and dropped them and
were surprised at how convincing the
fake man was that was of course until he
politely asks them not to touch him this
time they really did scream like girls
running straight out of the basement
into a local police station this
basement apartment was where Robert
chetford moved following the fire in his
parents home and the death of his
paralyzed mother racked with guilt he
had never been quite able to process
what had happened to cause his mother's
mental state to deteriorate so rapidly
by the time she died she had been
looking at her hands and genuinely
believed they were made of concrete she
would not move she would not eat she
would not sleep for days she would just
sit staring out of her window he knew he
should have taken her to a doctor but
they just couldn't afford it maybe if he
had this would have all worked out
differently Robert would think about it
hour after hour he would sit down in the
armchair in the corner of his room and
Ponder what had happened it was
difficult to keep track of time living
in the basement there were no windows no
daylight at all but he didn't think he
had been sitting there for very very
long when he noticed the skin on his
hands starting to turn gray without
Panic he slowly lifted his hands to his
eyes and inspected what was happening
his fingers down to about halfway
through his palms were dry and solid he
could move them just about but it took a
normal effort and he could see cracks
running along the back of the concrete
when he did so he decided not to he
wouldn't say he felt calm exactly maybe
disconnected he didn't feel particularly
hungry he didn't feel particularly tired
in fact he didn't feel much at all his
concrete limbs were only a passing
curiosity to him as he sat in his chair
very occasionally he would get up to put
on a record on his record player then
return to his seat and stare at the wall
that would be every couple of months at
most the rest of the time he would just
sit there one day he noticed in a vague
corner of his mind that the ground was
shaking and dust was filling the room
The Ripping sound of dynamite and the
heavy Stone just above his head told him
that the apartment block towering over
him had fallen down and almost come
through his ceiling Robert just sat
there unconcerned another day some
indeterminate time later a group of
Builders came in dressed in Peculiar
futuristic clothing with bright yellow
hats and reflective vests they seemed
rather startled to see him though in
truth he had little care for seeing them
what did perturb him was when a group of
people claiming the agents from the
foundation came into his room and
carried him out he didn't like the noise
didn't like the change if he wanted to
move he would move not that he could of
course he was now entirely made of
concrete but that was beside the point
these people put him in the back of a
van and drove him across half of the
United States they wheeled him through
brightly lit rooms and into a disgusting
modern white box they had done the
courtesy of bringing his chair along and
found a new record player for him with a
whole selection of albums lining a shelf
on the wall he would have appreciated it
and said thank you to them but he didn't
really care he wasn't present at all
this was of course due to the fact that
he was made of concrete by this point
however once he was sat in his chair and
took in the sight in front of him Robert
chedford felt a dull Panic rising in his
chest they placed him at a window just
like he'd placed his dying mother in
front of a window he tried to clench his
jaw tried to move his hands tried to cry
out in fear and pain but he couldn't he
was paralyzed the smell of smoke filled
his chest choking him torturing him as
the memories of his burning household
raged in his mind he tried to scream he
tried to fight he tried to do anything
other than just sit there but it was far
too late for any of that good afternoon
Mr chetford the researcher said busying
herself and putting on another album for
him to listen to is there anything I can
do for you sir anything I can do to make
you more comfortable the concrete man
said nothing the researcher patted him
on the back of his hand made of concrete
indeed looks just like regular skin to
me Mr chetford I do wonder what's going
on inside that head of yours on her way
out of the room she glanced at his view
from the window beautiful weather
outside today isn't it scorching even
gamma would never forget the horrific
site of
scp-5967 on the surface she kept her
nerve cool and collected her finger
ready to squeeze the trigger as her
weapons stayed trained on the entity but
deep down it turned her stomach after
all how is someone meant to react when
they see a thing like that a mess of
Flesh and eyeballs towering above them
staring back through more retinas than
any living creature has she did not yet
know it but she'd still be seeing that
disgusting pillar of musculature and
eyes in her nightmares for months to
come and still it wasn't even the worst
part of the incursion far worse than
seeing the five meter tall eyeball totem
watching it blink its many Lids at her
was witnessing what it had done to Alpha
only moments before gamma's commanding
officer had been in control of this
situation leading mobile task force
Lambda 5 into the Meadowlands of East
Rutherford New Jersey the mission should
have been a simple Smash and grab the
same old boring story their team had
lived through countless times before
pick up a high value Target the leader
of yet another cult practicing and
anomalous religion and bring him in for
questioning gamma never could have
expected that things would go this badly
the task force had arrived to discover
Caesar Winters the leader of a sect of
fifths operating in New Jersey when
Lambda 5 discovered him Winters and his
followers locals who were all members of
a group known as the commune were
standing in a circle around an instance
of
scp-5967 standing at around 5 meters in
height as CP 5967s were piles comprised
of mostly musculature and organs that
resembled eyeballs human eyeballs
despite lacking a mouth vocal cords or
any other conventional methods of speech
these pillars could still very much
communicate verbally although they had
little to say besides spouting phrases
and principles associated with the
fittest ideology almost immediately the
plan to capture winter had gone awry it
was almost like he expected the
foundation to arrive like he knew they
were coming as the members of MTF Lambda
5 moved in keeping Winters in their
sights the anomalous cult leader somehow
turned the Gaze of
scp-5967 onto Alpha the team's field
commander ordered Delta to open fire
taking out Caesar Winters in a single
shot but only for a moment another of
the commune members kneeled over and
began convulsing a wound formed at the
person's neck and from it emerged Caesar
Winter's face it grew into a full-sized
head replacing that of the commune
member giving Winters a brand new body
in moments on Alpha's orders to stop
Winters from hopping to more bodies
gamma and the others in their team fired
on the other cultists everyone was
terminated 15 seconds was all it took
then they moved towards
scp-5967 and everything went wrong the
bodies started to convulse violently as
if some unseen hand was shaking them
around like ragdolls gamma watched as
they began to levitate hoisted by their
necks and floating towards the mobile
task force not one of them knew what to
do keeping their rifles up and trained
on the corpses each one folded in on
itself becoming compressed masses of
muscle embedded with eyes that was when
the team lost Alpha something was
happening to their leader she had
dropped her weapon and Fallen to her
knees immediately gamma moved in to help
her commander trying to pull her back to
her feet but Alpha was resisting
transfixed by
scp-5967 it's
she is lost deep in the cosmos and is
angry with us for not helping her find
her way back she will kill us all lest
we line our brains and see her for who
she truly is gamma watched as her team
leaders Rush towards the pillar of eyes
and licked it the floating orbs of Flesh
and eyes that had once been people
suddenly hurtled towards the members of
MTF Lambda 5 at high speed gamma Dove
Clear at the vital moment performing a
tactical role and managing to narrowly
avoid being struck beta wasn't so lucky
ready to retaliate gamma raises a weapon
to fire the floating remains only to
hear Alpha ordering her to stop she had
stopped licking
scp-5967 but whatever influence had
compromised the mobile task force leader
hadn't relinquished its hold over her
she grinned unnervingly as her eyes
rolled back into her head don't you hear
her voice she is angry but I can save
you I can say save us let me show you
Alpha said before charging at Gamma with
her arms outstretched in seconds before
she could defend against her commanding
officer gamma found herself pounced upon
by Alpha grabbing a nearby Rock Alpha
swung at her head and knocked gamma's
tactical helmet clean off pinning her
down possessed by some unknown anomalous
entity Alpha held open gamma's eyelids
and licked her eyeball gamma screamed in
horror as Alpha looked up to the sky and
yelled I can see you I could see
everything now the case of
scp-5967 is one of the stranger Tales
within the annals of the SCP
foundation's history their investigation
that led to the discovery of these five
foot tall pillars of eyes and muscle
originally began with a different
intention the commune had been making
waves in Lindhurst New Jersey the kind
of waves that had caught the SCP
foundation's attention the two leaders
of this apparent cult were Salem steros
and Caesar Winters both of whom seem to
be able to use
scp-5967s to take control of the local
residents mines anyone that they
affected could be controlled remotely by
either steros or Winters with a
seemingly unlimited range and no known
way of relinquishing their control over
an affected person amnestic treatments
hypnotherapy none of the foundation's
usual methods had worked undercover
Foundation operatives working secretly
within the Lindhurst Police Department
were the first to discover an instance
of
scp-5967 right under their noses
literally the pillar of eyeballs seemed
to have sprouted up right in the middle
of the Lindhurst police station the
foundation sent in containment teams to
secure the area and administer amnestics
to Witnesses but just how were steros
and Winters causing these monstrous
musculature monoliths to appear well the
pair operated a radio show together
known as the reality sink the foundation
agents Within and Hurst had been unable
to track down exactly where they were
broadcasting from however after the
scp-5967 instance appeared within the
police station the answer seemed to
present itself during the building's
reconstruction tapes of their radio show
were recovered seeming to suggest that
the pair had been utilizing anomalous
means to broadcast the reality sync from
within the station itself while keeping
themselves concealed the reality sync
was a religious talk show specifically
focused on discussing elements of
fifthism with the audience and callers
who phoned into Winters and steros's
hidden Studio what exactly is fifthism
well there's no easy answer to that
question unfortunately other anomalous
Cults and religions at least have a core
tenet or belief at their Center
sarcasism is the worship of disease and
Decay while mechanites from the church
of the broken God venerate technology
the beliefs of the fifth church are a
little more interchangeable however they
don't really have any defined theology
or religious practices fifthism is often
more just a collection of recurring
ideas and motifs the number five stars
and the belief in an external Cosmic God
often a malicious one in fact if there
is a defining principle of fifthism it's
that it's an anomalous way of thinking
that it can't really be understood
practitioners of fifthism are concerned
primarily with transcending reality as
we perceive it they are highly
interested in entities and anomalies
that can warp and shape reality to the
extent of even being fearful of such
beings a lot of fithas seek to not only
spread their influence to others through
any means necessary including
brainwashing but also hope to transcend
Humanity to a higher plane of reality
The Fifth Dimension there in theory a
person would cease to be a human being
and wouldn't even really be akin to a
god or powerful reality Bender instead
they would become something more vague a
concept unable to be fully defined or to
exist in reality completely fithus
follow this goal presumably with the
intention of saving humankind from
reality warping anomalies and they'll
use any infectious brainwashing Methods
at their disposal to bring as many
people as they can into their way of
thinking this brings us neatly back to
Caesar Winters and Salem steros's Radio
Show the reality sink this was the
communes their particular sect of
fithism's way of spreading what they
referred to as the truth based on the
various fragmented cassette recordings
of their show that the SCP Foundation
were able to recover both steros and
Winters believed in a many armed goddess
referring to it as only she or her they
encourage their listeners to pray to
this entity and let her know that they
were loyal to her during one of their
recovered broadcasts the pair of fithus
hosts were even able to prank call the
SCP Foundation itself one Junior
researcher Jones was contacted by the
two men and ridiculed for his
association with the SCP Foundation but
after a few jokes at Junior researcher
Jones's expense steros and Winters began
to insidiously implant ideas of fifthism
in the researcher's head they referred
to this as giving Jones the truth
something they both intended to do for
all of their listeners in order to save
them when asked what they really meant
Winters and steros made vague allusions
to the truth being an infinite knowledge
that only she could bestow Jones had no
idea who she was meant to be our Guiding
Light our creator Salem described before
adding the very thoughts that should be
infiltrating your head right now it
seemed that through this call The Two
Hosts had managed to successfully embed
their fittest Concepts into the mind of
Junior researcher Jones and they weren't
about to stop there during another call
on their show both hosts spoke with a
Wallington New Jersey resident named
Wendy Ricefield who was already a
self-proclaimed fittest steros and
Winters talked Wendy through a ritual to
learn the truth involving her drawing
sigils on the walls and floor of her
home and lighting candles the phone line
picked up wet squelching noises coming
from the other side the splintering of
wood and Wendy screaming for help as she
tried to run from her home only for
something to drag her back inside
eventually the foundation made the
executive decision to step in and deal
with the situation in New Jersey
directly steros and winters's operation
was getting out of hand more and more
people in the surrounding area were
being brainwashed into believing in
fifthis Concepts and compelled to
complete bizarre rituals sending a team
in to apprehend the cult leaders
Foundation Personnel discovered Salem
steros and numerous other members of the
commune they had gathered at an instance
of
scp-5967 that had manifested in
Wallington the same place that Wendy
Ricefield had been from steros and his
fifth his followers were discovered
holding hands fans and standing in a
circle around the anomalous pillar of
eyeballs as well as approaching it and
licking
scp-5967 the members of the commune were
rounded up and most were sent to be kept
in isolation at site 9. however Salem
steros was brought to site-83 for
questioning Junior researcher Umar Hadid
conducted an interview as to the exact
nature of the Goddess her that steros
and Winters often referred to and the
anomalous rituals the pair had been
involved with Salem was less than
Cooperative he demanded to be set free
in the interest of saving people by
spreading the truth with Caesar however
he did reveal some key information about
her according to steros's claims she was
a goddess actively meddling with reality
and influencing human actions he told
Hadid that if he killed the junior
researcher right there it would be
because she willed it sometime before
both Salem and his cult co-leader Caesar
had been stargazing in the Meadowlands a
remote field in East Rutherford that's
when they had allegedly heard her voice
and being told the truth this reality
warping goddess was intending to return
home but that way was broken so
according to steros she needed their
help this was the reason he and Winters
began creating instances of
scp-5967 the eyeball pillars apparently
acted as beacons like a GPS signal
allowing her to come back the pair and
the rest of the commune were attempting
to prove their loyalty to her in the
hopes that they would potentially be
allowed to transcend reality in
accordance with the fifthis principle
Salem steros was remained into SCP
Foundation custody and kept attained in
a containment Suite surrounded by three
Scranton reality anchors shortly after
the members of MTF Lambda 5 were
dispatched heading to the location
steros had inadvertently revealed during
his interrogation their mission was to
rest Caesar Winters who remained at
large after the leader of Lambda 5 was
compromised eventually gamma was able to
contact the foundation who sent a
containment team as backup they secured
the surviving MTF operative along with
the infected team leader Alpha and the
instance of
scp-5967 on the scene gamma was offered
medical treatment and presented with a
silver lion badge for her efforts in the
field along with a two-week vacation as
a reward that did little to stop the
nightmares though she wasn't the same
and neither was Alpha after two long
weeks of psychological screening and no
further hostile or anomalous activity
Alpha was interviewed by Junior
researcher Hadid during their discussion
Alpha real name Cassandra Sandy denofsky
described that she could still hear
voices in her head rambling about the
truth fifthism and eyeballs amnestic
treatment wasn't helping suddenly
someone within the foundation played a
clip of Caesar winters's voice over the
facility facility speakers taken from
one of his and steros's radio broadcasts
it triggered an instant paranoid
reaction from Sandy followed by her
opening her mouth and revealing
something growing inside another eyeball
some kind of post-hypnotic suggestion or
other form of brainwashing had affected
her and she began exhibiting anomalous
Behavior tell me Hadid are you a fitness
now she asked the junior researcher are
you ready to see the truth Hadid rushed
out of the room shutting the door behind
him pacing around the room Sandy started
drawing strange sigils of Unknown Origin
on the floor and walls biting a candle
through anomalous means then there came
a bright flash of light as a four-legged
entity appeared and attacked Alpha the
two merged causing her body to change
until it was unrecognizable well it's
human anyway standing in the
interrogation room where Sandy had been
standing was a contorted mass of Flesh
and muscle with multiple eyeballs
staring out from it she had turned into
another instance of
scp-5967 they all had they were people
steros and Winters had made beacons out
of living people now check out scp-3760
like a doll's eyes and the iPods scp-131
for more